[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans les matins du
sénat la semaine dernière le
gouvernement présenté son plan pour
relancer l'économie un plan de 100
milliards d'euros destinée à faire
repartir la machine alors que l'épidémie
de coronavirus n'est toujours pas
éradiqué mais de nombreuses questions
restent en suspens notamment sur la
conditionnalité de certaines aides c'est
dans ce cadre que bruno le maire est
aujourd'hui auditionné par la commission
des finances
regarde l'audition n'en reparle juste
après sur public sénat jeudi réponse à
ce qui ne marche pas et d'accélérer et
de renforcer ce qui marche c'est ce qui
fait d'ailleurs que le choix que nous
avons fait dans ce plan de relance et
que je revendique puisque nous y
travaillons depuis six mois et le choix
d'un plan par l'investissement et par
l'offre
l'allemagne a fait un choix différent
c'est parfaitement normal l'allemagne a
rétabli la compétitivité de son offre
depuis vingt ans mais elle a un problème
de demande que nous avions souligné il
ya maintenant plusieurs mois
donc l'allemagne répond à son problème
de demande et conforte son offre la
france elle doit continuer à répondre à
son problème d'offre investir pour
moderniser son outil de production pour
créer les emplois de demain
sinon nous serions tous comptables d'une
relégation de l'économie française au
deuxième plan c'est le choix stratégique
qui a été fait par le présent la
république par le premier ministre et
par moi-même
la deuxième remarque que je veux faire
c'est que ce plan de relance n'est que
la troisième vague de la réponse nous
avons apportées à la crise la première
c'est et l'amortissement du choc et nous
avons mis tous les moyens nécessaires
et croyez-moi ça demande aussi une
certaine révolution mentale quand on a
été plus de trois ans ministre de
l'économie et des finances de se dire on
a essayé de moins dépenser on a essayé
de rétablir les finances publiques et
nous étions sur le point d'y arriver
nous avions moins stabilisé nos finances
publiques
mais à cause de la crise il faut
dépenser massivement de l'argent public
pour sauver des emplois
et pour sauver des entreprises si
c'était à refaire je referais exactement
la même chose mais c'est un choix
difficile parce qu'il est coûteux
effectivement pour les finances
publiques
nous avons mis en place un certain
nombre de dispositifs vous les
connaissez je les rappelle brièvement
ils ont très bien fonctionné et ils ont
invité non seulement la casse économique
mais je pense aussi de la casse sociale
et de la casse politique
nous avons mis en place un prêt garanti
par l'état à hauteur de 300 milliards
d'euros 120 milliards d'euros ont déjà
été décaissés
nous avons mis en place un fonds de
solidarité pour les très petites
entreprises pour les indépendants il a
très bien fonctionné également nous
avons fait des exonérations et les
reports de charges sociales et fiscales
et nous avons mis en place un instrument
massif pour le chômage partiel qui va
représenter cette année plus de 28
milliards d'euros mais qui nous a évité
des dizaines de milliers de
licenciements sur nos territoires
la deuxième vague ça a été celle de la
réponse sectorielle parce que des
secteurs sont plus touchés que d'autres
et cette intuition ne fait qu être
confirmée dans cette rentrée de
septembre
oui l'aéronautique est très durement
touchée pour une raison qui est simple
c'est que personne ne sait quand est ce
que les avions décolleront et quand est
ce que le trafic aérien retournera à la
normale
personne ne le sait il faut avoir
l'humilité de le reconnaître
non seulement parce qu'on ne sait pas
comment le commerce mondial va reprendre
et comment est-ce que des activités
économiques vont reprendre niveau
mondial personne ne sait ce que sera
l'évolution des relations entre les
états unis et la chine
et personne ne sait non plus comment
est-ce que nous allons tous
collectivement réagir au transport par
avion et que nous allons leur prendre
régulièrement à ce que nous allons moins
d'utiliser personne ne le sait et rien
n'est pire pour un secteur industriel
que l'incertitude et l'incertitude sur
le transport aérien et total seront donc
faits
un plan massif de soutien à l'industrie
aéronautique qui se montrent très utile
aujourd'hui pour répondre aux demandes
des pme pour restructurer un certains
nombre d'industries qui avait besoin de
l'être pour mettre en place de
l'activité partielle dans des
entreprises qui en ont cruellement
besoin ou pour financer par des
garanties export le maintien de
commandes de compagnies aériennes qui
sinon annulerait leurs commandes d'a380
ou d'a350 nous mettons beaucoup d'argent
là-dessus parce que ce qui est en cause
c'est la survie d'air france
la défense d'airbus la protection de
milliers de pme sous-traitantes de
l'industrie aéronautique
nous avons fait la même chose pour
l'industrie automobile
parce que l'industrie automobile
représente des centaines de milliers
d'emplois entre pays et que nous étions
en train de réussir la transition du
véhicule thermique sur lequel la france
a été champion pendant tout le xxème
siècle aux véhicules électriques sur
laquelle j'en suis convaincu la france
sera une des nations leaders au 21ème
siècle
donc nous n'avions pas laisser
s'effondrer tout cet effort perdre nos
compétences perdre nos centres
techniques perdre nos usines
donc nous avons investi massivement soit
du scot aux bobines c'est un deuxième
choix sectoriels que nous avons fait ça
très bien marché notamment sur le
soutien à la demande puisque la prime à
la conversion était un grand succès que
nous avons vendu 45 mille véhicules
électriques en l'espace de quelques mois
que nous avons vendu plus de voitures en
france en juin 2020 qu'en juin 2019
le troisième secteur que nous avons
voulu soutenir c'est celui du tourisme
de l'hôtellerie de la restauration de
l'événementiel et de la culture
c'est un secteur qui reste aujourd'hui
très fragilisée et chacun ne jure bien
que même si la saison a été très bonne
sur certains points du territoire
étaient très bonnes sa façade atlantique
elle était très bonne sur la côte basque
chère à mon coeur était très bonne dans
beaucoup de stations de montagne
mais elle a été extrêmement difficile
dans les lieux qui accueillent des
touristes étrangers
je pense à à paris évidemment aux
grandes métropoles je pense aussi une
ville comme lourdes où j'ai eu
l'occasion de me rendre cet été et par
ailleurs il n'y a pas d'arrière saison
tout l'arrière saison qui repose sur les
congrès et il activités économiques
malheureusement est aujourd'hui sinistré
donc c'est un secteur qui reste en
grande difficulté c'est pourquoi nous
avons pris la décision de maintenir le
chômage partiel
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020 pour ce
secteur-là qui en a je le redis
cruellement besoin
nous entrons maintenant dans ce
troisième temps qui est celui de la
relance et de ce choix que nous avons
fait d'un plan de relance par
l'investissement
ce plan de relance par l'investissement
représente 100 milliards d'euros je
tiens à dire tout de suite que relance
par l'investissement ne veut pas dire
comme je l'entend trop souvent que nous
n'aurions pas soutenu la demande
j'ai donné l'exemple de l'industrie
automobile nous avons soutenu la demande
de voitures
le chômage partiel qu'est ce que c'est
sinon soutenir la demande les 28
milliards d'euros ont permis de
préserver les salaires donc de préserver
la demande donc ne caricaturons pas les
choses
je crois que ce serait inexact et que
nous avons besoin dans ces temps qui
sont difficiles de concertation de
dialogue de critiques constructives mais
certainement pas de caricature il y a eu
un soutien massif la demande par
l'emploi et ç'a toujours été le choix
cohérent du présent la république et de
cette majorité
nous soutenons le pouvoir d'achat et la
demande par l'emploi
quand il ya eu la crise et gilet jaune
une demande de pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire n'ayant pas distribuer
des chèques
nous avons augmenté la prime d'activité
pour que les salariés au niveau du smic
qui se touchent et 100 euros de plus
seront défiscaliser des heures
supplémentaires donc nous avons soutenu
le travail etc
cette cohérence qui restent à l'oeuvre
dans le plan de relance dans le soutien
à la demande
nous soutenons la demande par le travail
et par la meilleure rémunération du
travail
je rappelle au passage que la prime
d'activité représente aujourd'hui en
année pleine
près de 10 milliards d'euros de dépenses
publiques c'est un soutien massif à la
demande et nous restons dans cette
cohérence fixées par le présent la
république depuis le premier jour le
travail doit payer et c'est par le
travail
la défense de l'emploi et la
rémunération du travail qu'on défend le
mieux de pouvoir d'achat des français
et ça restera notre ligne s'agissant du
soutien à la demande et de ce plan
d'investissement de la relance à 100
milliards d'euros
il repose sur trois grandes priorités et
sur une méthode que je m'appliquerai à
conserver tant que j'exercerai mes
fonctions de ministre de l'économie et
des finances la première priorité c'est
l'accélération de la transition
écologique
quand je dis que la france peut sortir
plus forte de cette crise économique
c'est qu'elle peut profiter de cette les
économies pour accélérer la transition
écologique en trouvant dans ce plan de
relance les investissements qui étaient
nécessaires et dont nous ne disposions
pas jusqu'à présent nous devons sortir
de la crise économique avec une économie
qui émet moins de co2 c'est une attente
fondamental de nos compatriotes et nous
pouvons conjuguer ambitions économiques
et réconciliation de la nation autour de
cet objectif de décarbonation l'économie
nous cherchons des thèmes qui rassemble
l'accélération de la transition
écologique rassemble nous cherchons des
sujets de débats constructifs la
transition écologique est un sujet de
débat constructif à quel rythme on y va
comme on y va avec quelle technologie en
mettant des investissements sur quels
types d'industries ça ce sont de beaux
débats et des débats qui à mon sens
rassemble la nation française nous
allons cibler ces 30 milliards d'euros
d'investissements sur l'objectif de
transition écologique sur quatre
secteurs qui sont les plus émetteurs de
co2 en france le bâtiment les transports
l'industrie et l'agriculture
s'agissant du bâtiment il est à
l'origine d'un quart des émissions de
co2 nous allons donc engager un plan
massif de
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
publics et privés de près de 7 milliards
d'euros pour les bâtiments publics et
vous êtes directement concernés comme
élus locaux universités écoles centres
de service public
des appels à projets sont lancés pour
assurer une sélection efficace et une
exécution rapide des rénovations
je ne saurais trop vous recommander de
participer à ces appels à projets est
d'inciter les maires de vos communes à
participer à ces appels à projets pour
qu'on puisse le plus vite possible
sortir des rénovations énergétiques de
bâtiments publics et j'ajoute que avec
olivier dussopt nous sommes tout à fait
ouverts à reprendre des projets qui sont
déjà en cours ou sur lesquels appels
d'offres ont déjà été passés plus vite
ça va mieux c'est donc si des appels
d'offres ont déjà été passées pour la
rénovation d'une école dans une commune
de 2000 habitants et que cette
rénovation manque d'argent a pas inventé
un nouveau projet alors que nous avons
l'argent pour financer ce projet et nous
assurer que le chantier démarre le plus
vite possible au service de tous je veux
que les choses soient très claires là
dessus ça vaut pour les petites communes
rurales
ça vaut pour les villes moyennes qui
vont faire l'objet d'un effort
spécifique
ça vaut aussi pour les grandes
métropoles et ça me permet d'insister
sur la philosophie politique de ce plan
de relance
il faut rassembler les français donc
nous n'allons pas regarder la couleur
politique de tel ou tel métropole pour
savoir si on soutient un tel ou tel
projet nous voulons soutenir le plus
grand nombre de projets possibles
s'agissant de la rénovation des
bâtiments privés
nous allons renforcer ma prime rénove
qui a passé de 800 millions d'euros à 2
milliards d'euros
tous les français quel que soit leur
niveau de revenu auront accès à cette
nouvelle prime nous avons fait un choix
économique
là aussi je l'assumé totalement ma prime
rénove été réservé aux ménages les plus
modestes mais il se trouve que 50% des
travaux de rénovation énergétique sont
faits par le 8e et par le 9ème décile
donc exclure le 8e 2 9e décile
du bénéfice de ma prime rénove ses être
certain que la relance économique ne
marchera pas et comme nous voulons
qu'elle marché qu'elles marchent vite
nous avons fait le choix d'ouvrir ma
prime rénove à l'ensemble des ménages
français quel que soit leur niveau de
revenu ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'ils ne
toucheront le même montant de primes
mais ce qui veut dire simplement que la
prime est accessible à tous au bénéfice
de la relance économique
s'agissant des transports nous allons
lancer de grands plans pour développer
le vélo les transports en commun et les
transports ferroviaires nous mettrons
près de cinq milliards d'euros sur le
transport ferroviaire pour à la fois
éponger les pertes qui sont liées au co
vide et elles sont considérables pour
rénover un certain nombre de lignes
ferroviaires
je crois que certains incidents récents
ont montré que c'était nécessaire pour
ouvrir un certain nombre de petites
lignes dont le nom ne sera arrêté par le
premier ministre d'ici quelques jours
pour relancer le fret ferroviaire à
hauteur de 300 millions d'euros
et pour ouvrir au moins une ligne de
trains de nuit entre paris et nice
d'autres pourraient suivre si jamais la
rentabilité de ces lignes et est garanti
le troisième émetteur c'est l'industrie
nous allons nous attaquer résolument à
décarbonation des sites industriels
ces sites représentent 20% des émissions
de gaz à effet serre et ses émissions
sont concentrés en fait sur un petit
nombre de sites qui sont
particulièrement émetteurs nous allons
les accompagner pour qu'il passe
concrètement de chaudières à énergie
fossile à des chaudières à biomasse et
des chaudières moins émettrices de co2
c'est coûteux c'est un investissement et
c'est moins rentables en termes de coûts
de fonctionnement nous allons compenser
ce manque à gagner pour les industries
pour qu'elle puisse accélérer la
décarbonation de leurs processus
les premiers appels à projets ont été
lancés fin août c'est vous dire si
nombre de ces mesures j'aurai l'occasion
d'y revenir sont déjà disponibles et
n'attendront pas le vote du pf dans
l'agriculture enfin nous allons investir
pour accélérer la transition agricole va
culture biologique et vers les circuits
courts ils sont aussi une forte attente
de nos compatriotes
la deuxième grande orientation tout
aussi stratégique que la première et qui
est un vrai tournant dans l'histoire de
notre économie c'est la relocalisation
de l'industrie en france
ce mouvement nous l'inscrivons dans un
mouvement plus global que nous voyons à
travers la planète qui est celui d'un
recentrage de la mondialisation la
mondialisation qui se descendre de plus
en plus avec une espèce de mouvement
brownien qui ne s'arrête jamais cette
mondialisation là elle est finie je ne
crois pas à la démondialisation mais je
suis convaincu que la mondialisation est
en train d'entrer dans une nouvelle ère
où les centres de production vont se
recentrer sur un certain nombre de
continents
on voit ce mouvement à l'oeuvre en chine
on le voit aux états unis et il faut le
construire aussi en europe
nous devons renforcer notre souveraineté
industrielle relocaliser des productions
soient stratégiques soit à haute valeur
ajoutée
exactement comme le président qui a
annoncé qu'il allait le fait les
quelques semaines en disant que le temps
de la chine ouverte était finie et que
la chine devait maintenant s'appuyer sur
son propre marché pour se développer
beaucoup plus que sont les échanges
commerciaux il faut que nous en tirions
les conséquences quand vous avez un
marché de 2 4 milliards d'habitants que
le plus dynamique de la planète qui vous
dit qu'il va se refermer sur lui-même
soyons lucides et comprenons qu'il est
peut-être temps que nous aussi nous
soyons capables de relocaliser un
certain nombre d'activités industrielles
en france
entendons nous bien sûr cette
relocalisation et ne sont pas croire aux
français qu'on va relocaliser toutes les
activités industrielles y compris celles
à faible valeur ajoutée en france c'est
faux ne soyons pas compétitifs là dessus
et ça n'aurait pas de sens mais nous
pouvons relocaliser deux types
d'activités les premières je le redis
celles qui sont stratégiques pour notre
souveraineté exemple les principes
actifs de médicaments nous avons
découvert à l'occasion de la crise
sanitaire que nous
et pandion de l'asie pour un certain
nombre de principes actifs de
médicaments qui sont fondamentaux pour
endormir les patients pour atténuer la
douleur
personne ne peut accepter qu'une grande
nation comme la france soit dépendant de
l'asie pour des biens aussi stratégique
et je redis à quel point il est possible
d'y arriver
d'abord parce que nous avons une
industrie pharmaceutique les puissantes
et ensuite parce que en termes de
compétitivité
l'augmentation progressive des salaires
en chine fait que notre compétitivité
coût gagne aussi relativement à la chine
année après année et que si nous nous
positionnons sur des biens à forte
valeur ajoutée
nous pouvons y arriver les deuxièmes
filières industrielles sur lesquels nous
pouvons investir largement ses des
filières à haute valeur ajoutée exemple
les batteries électriques faut bien
mesurer la faute économique que ce
serait vis-à-vis des générations qui
viennent que de dire l'automobile de
demain sera électrique
mais un tiers de la valeur sera produit
en chine ou en corée du sud qui
produisent aujourd'hui 87 % de nos
batteries électriques
vous pouvez pas garantir l'avenir de
l'industrie en france en laissant la
valeur en asie
c'est totalement incohérent c'est
pourquoi pas ont pris la décision avec
petter altmeyer et mon homologue
allemand il ya près de deux ans de bâtir
une filière des batteries électriques en
europe sur la base d'un accord
franco-allemand qui est étendu à
d'autres partenaires comme par exemple
la pologne
nous avons une usine pilote à nersac en
nouvelles aquitaine en charente
nous ouvrirons en 2022 la première usine
de production de masse à douvrin dans le
nord et à deuxième usine sera ouverte à
kaiserslautern en 2024
en allemagne c'est la première fois
depuis airbus que l'europe recréer une
filière de production industrielle
indépendante d'un bout à l'autre de la
chaîne
quand on voit aujourd'hui l'explosion de
la consommation de véhicules électriques
je pense que c'est un choix stratégique
absolument essentielles au delà des
batteries électriques
nous allons investir 11 milliards
d'euros dans ces nouveaux marchés
la production d'hydrogène vers les
biotech le développement des
technologies quantiques feront partie de
ces nouveaux marchés et garantiront la
relocalisation industrielle
quand vous regardez là aussi le panorama
économique français une chose vous
frappe
nous nous sommes reposés sur nos
lauriers et nous vivons sur nos acquis
nous avons quelques magnifiques filières
industrielles je pense vous luxe je
pense à l'agroalimentaire je pense à la
pharmacie je pense à l'aéronautique mais
c'est toujours les quatre mêmes qu'on
cite et ça depuis 20 ans et nous n'avons
pas été capables depuis 20 ans de créer
de nouvelles chaînes de valeur en france
qui permettent cette relocalisation
industrielle nous allons pour la
première fois depuis 20 ans
créer de nouvelles chaînes de valeur en
france pour garantir cette
relocalisation industrielle
si vous voulons atteindre cet objectif
et ne pas nous contenter de grandes
déclarations mais je pense que les
batteries électriques montre que nous
avons passé des paroles aux actes
ce que nous avons fait son hydrogène
monde nous allons passer des paroles aux
actes
ce que nous faisons sur le calcul
quantique monde que nous allons passer
des paroles aux actes ce qui est
essentiel pour les français il faut en
assumer les conséquences en terme
d'attractivité de notre territoire et de
fiscalité
c'est ce qui explique le choix de baisse
de 10 milliards d'euros des impôts de
production qui figure dans le plan de
relance et vous voyez bien que cette
baisse des impôts de production je la
met en regard de notre volonté politique
de relocaliser des activités
industrielles en france
pas une baisse qui décidons comme ça dix
milliards d'euros dans un claquement de
doigts c'est parce que nous avons
regardé qu'est ce qui permettait de
garantir la relocalisation industrielle
en france il faut des compétences
il faut des marchés il faut un minimum
de tissu industriel si nous engageons
temps sur l'hydrogène par exemple c'est
parce que nous avons
un liquide que nous ne partons pas de
rien et donc on a toute la base
industrielle pour aller plus loin mais
la condition sinequanone c'est d'être
compétitif en terme fiscal par rapport à
nos voisins et vous pouvez pas demande
de l'industrie française de courir avec
des boulets aux pieds
sinon vous rester dans la logique qui
est celle des trente dernières années
la délocalisation et la suppression
d'emplois industriels nous voulons
réussir cette relocalisation
industrielle nous ne pouvons pas avoir
des impôts de production deux fois plus
élevé que la moyenne européenne
cette fois plus élevé qu'en allemagne
nous allons donc baisser ses impôts de
production de 10 milliards d'euros par
an dès le 1er janvier 2021
nous avons décidé de concentrer cette
baisse en cohérence avec ce que je viens
de vous dire sur les activités
industrielles
nous avons donc écarté l'option qui
était l'option la plus simple pour moi
comme ministre des finances pour olivier
comme ministre chargé des comptes
publics qui aurait été la suppression de
la c3s c3 est une recette pour l'état
donc ont supprimé à ses trois essais
c'est une perte pour l'état il n'est pas
de difficultés particulières avec les
collectivités locales
sauf que la c3s bénéficient en priorité
au secteur financier
alors je sais bien qu'il ya un effet de
cascade des services financiers vers
l'industrie mais c'est un effet de
cascade
je préfère supprimer directement ce qui
pénalise l'industrie
c'est à dire la cvae et les impôts
fonciers soit locaux industriels
je m'arrête une seconde là dessus parce
que vous êtes évidemment directement
concerné la cvae sera divisé de moitié
pour passer de 14 à 7 milliards d'euros
la part régionale cvae sera supprimé et
en accord avec les régions notamment le
président de la r f
renaud muselier que je salue pour son
esprit constructif et la qualité du
dialogue que nous avons eu nous avons
trouvé un accord signé au niveau du prix
ministre sur une compensation de cette
recette la cvae pour l'apa régional par
une part de tva
c'est à dire une recette dynamique qui
garantit une bonne compensation pour
les régions sur les impôts fonciers
soyez locaux industriels que sont la cfe
et la taxe foncière sur les propriétés
bâties elles seront aussi divisé par
deux pour alléger le 3 milliards d'euros
les impôts des entreprises industrielles
3 milliards au titre de ses impôts
fonciers 7 milliards au titre de la cvae
par régionales cela représente bien 10
milliards d'euros de baisses d'impôts de
production le principe mais olivier
dussopt vous expliquera tout cela je
pense dans le moindre détail parce que
je connais la sensibilité du sujet c'est
que les collectivités territoriales
seront intégralement compensés pour ces
baisses de recettes
elle se fera par une indemnisation
budgétaire mensuelle de façon à garantir
que au mois le mois
la compensation est intégrale et les
communes garderont de liberté de
fixation de taux je connais l'inquiétude
qui n'est plus à voir sur la libre
administration des collectivités locales
qui pourraient être menacés par ce choix
fiscal je veux vous confirmer avec
olivier du sorte que les communes
garderont liberté de fixation des taux
et je pense que olivier aura keun ho
apporter des précisions supplémentaires
sur ces éléments qui cela ne m'a pas
échappé non plus suscité un certain émoi
parmi les collectivités locales
la troisième grande orientation de ce
plan c'est la protection de l'emploi et
la formation aux métiers de demain
c'est un choix qui est cohérent par
rapport à tous les choix que nous avons
fait depuis le début de la crise
augmenter le chômage partiel comme nous
l'avons fait ce qui n'est pas eu de
précédent dans l'histoire économique
récente de la france ce qui correspond
choix qui a été fait en allemagne depuis
pour le coup plusieurs décennies nous a
permis de sauver des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois nous ne voulons pas
retirer ce soutien brutalement parce que
je pense que ce serait une erreur
nous avons donc maintenu le chômage
partiel avec un reste à charge de 15%
pour tous les secteurs les plus menacés
par la crise actuelle hôtellerie
restauration café et démentielles
culture l'évolution d'épidémie montrent
que malheureusement comme d'ailleurs je
pense l'avoir dit depuis le pr
jours le retour à la normale ne se fera
pas immédiatement donc ils y achètent
tous ces restaurateurs c'est tous ces
patrons de café chez tous les gérants
d'hôtels une inquiétude profonde que je
comprends et donc nous maintenons pour
répondre à cette inquiétude le chômage
partiel jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2020
et nous avisons à la fin de l'année 2020
en fonction la situation sanitaire
quelles sont les décisions que nous
prendrons et la méthode j'y reviendrai
par la suite sera toujours la même
l'écoutent et la modification des
dispositifs si nécessaire je pars pas du
principe que nous avons la vérité
révélée que tout cela est absolument
intangible
les événements récents nous ont montré
qu'il fallait faire preuve de souplesse
des coûte les capacités de changement
pour les dispositifs correspondent à la
réalité du terrain
s'agissant du chômage partiel nous
allons également mettre en place une
activité partielle de longue durée
l'accès à l'activité partielle va être
prolongée dans les conditions actuelles
au moins jusqu'au 1er novembre et au
delà pour toutes les entreprises qui ont
signé un accord sur activité partielle
de longue durée
et tout cela n'a de sens que si dans le
même temps nous préparons les salariés
aux métiers de demain saisit pas de
figer les situations saisi d'apporter le
soutien nécessaire pour que un certain
nombre de salariés puissent s'orienter
vers de nouvelles qualifications et les
métiers de demain nous allons donc
mettre en place pour la première fois
une gestion prévisionnelle des
compétences au niveau national pour que
dans chaque région nous puissions
identifier les compétences disponibles
et les besoins des entreprises
un mot enfin sur la méthode
la méthode sera décisive soit bonne
exécution du plan comme elle a été
absolument décisive sur la première
réponse de 460 milliards d'euros que
nous avons dégagé au moment de la crise
nous devons agir vite et nous devons
agir bien et je préfère retenir le choix
qui était le mien depuis le début du
mois de mars
c'était
agir le plus vite possible corrigés en
temps réel plutôt que d'attendre d'avoir
la pierre philosophale avant de bouger
le petit doigt
la situation est trop grave pour que
nous ne nions pas le plus vite possible
en corrigeant en chemin ce qui doit être
corrigé
le deuxième point de méthodes c'est la
consultation la plus large possible
ce plan de relance a demandé des mois de
consultation
tout ce qui a trait aux nouveaux marchés
industriels à la relocalisation
industrielle est issu de nos travaux sur
le pacte productif auquel vous avez
d'ailleurs participé côté lancé en
novembre 2019 si les 7 milliards d'euros
sur l'hydrogène sont désormais bien
ciblé bien orientées que des entreprises
comme mc fils comme berger air liquide
savent de quoi ils peuvent disposer quel
type de choix stratégiques que nous
faisons c'est tout simplement parce que
ça fait près de 1 an que nous
travaillons dessus et si le plan a
recueilli 72 % de soutien chez les
français c'est tout simplement ce que ce
plan n'est pas le plan du ministère de
l'économie et des finances c'est le plan
de relance est français bhatti avait été
chef d'entreprise a été salarié avec les
représentants syndicaux avec les
fédérations professionnelles avec les
économistes qui ont joué aussi un rôle
absolument fondamental et je continuerai
toutes les semaines à recevoir les
fédérations professionnelles pour voir
avec elle si le plan se développe dans
de bonnes conditions à échanger avec
vous mesdames et messieurs les élus
nationaux avaient été élus locaux
avaient des économistes parce que ce
plan nous engage tous il est évidemment
la responsabilité du gouvernement
mais le succès de ce plan il est
évidemment un succès qui nous engage
tous et dont dépend l'avenir notre
nation
troisième point sur la méthode si nous
voulons aller vite il faut qu'il y ait
une centralisation des crédits façon à
ce que nous puissions est décaissé le
plus vite possible nous assurer qu'ils
sont réellement décaissés les 100
milliards d'euros auront donc l'objet
d'une mission relance et grâce à la
direction du budget nous pourrons
veiller au décaissement de ces sommes au
jour le jour
si nous avions délégués les crédits
les ministères ou dans les
établissements publics ne pouvions pas
surveillé avec la même précision le
décaissement des crédits donc c'est par
souci d'efficacité que j'ai proposé au
présent la république auprès ministre
cette méthode nous allons également
prévoir sur chacune des grandes missions
des clauses extinction qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que sur un projet
par exemple une rénovation énergétique
d'université on mettra les sommes qui
seront demandés par l'université et si
nous voyons au bout d'un délai qui reste
à déterminer ça peut être trois mois ça
peut être six mois en fonction de l'état
d'avancement du projet ce que l'appel
d'offres était passée n'a pas été passée
nous nous réservons le droit avec le
premier ministre de réallouer les
crédits un projet qui serait plus avancé
ceux qui n'auront pas suffisamment vite
et qu'ils ne seront pas suffisamment
mobilisé sur le plan de relance la leurs
crédits seront réattribués a d'autres
qui vont plus vite qu'ils sont plus
mobilisés qui captent plus d'emplois et
qui soutienne davantage l'économie
il faudra s'assurer de la bonne
exécution du plan
donc au delà de cette méthode la
consultation la mission budgétaire
unique la clause d'extinction nous
aurons deux instruments pour veiller à
la bonne exécution
nous aurons tout d'abord au niveau du
prêt ministre un conseil de suivi qui
sera présidée par le premier ministre et
qui associera les partenaires sociaux et
parlementaires les élus le plus
largement possible pour garantir aussi
le rassemblement de la nation autour de
ce plan
je présiderai pour ma part un comité de
pilotage qui se réunira chaque semaine
dont le secrétariat général sera assurée
par l'ancien directeur général des
finances publiques
bruno parent que nous allons nommer
secrétaire général de ce comité de
pilotage et qui veillera avec la
direction du budget avec la direction
générale des finances publiques avec un
certain nombre de directions d'autres
ministères de la bonne exécution du plan
et du bon décaissement des sols ce
comité de pilotage qui je le redis se
réunira toutes les semaines et qui
associera d'autres ministères pour à
chaque semaine consulté un certain
nombre de parts
l'air qu'ils soient syndicaux
professionnelles ou autres de façon à
recueillir les remarques les critiques
et des observations nécessaire à tout
dernier mot enfin pour vous dire que les
dernières semaines nous ont tous appris
et les derniers mois à faire preuve de
beaucoup de pragmatisme et aussi
beaucoup de modestie dans les réponses
que nous apportons personne ne sait
comment la situation sanitaire va
évoluer
tout le monde regarde les chiffres
regarde l'évolution la situation se
compare avec d'autres pays à travers la
planète l'inde pour prendre un pays
lointain l'espagne pour prendre un pays
proche et il se demande de quoi demain
va être fait
et quand on aux compatriotes se demande
de quoi demain va être fait je pense que
la responsabilité politique c'est
justement de fixer un horizon
et d'expliquer où nous pouvons aller
alors on va passer par des tempêtes on
va passer par des moments de
découragement au passé par des moments
d'enthousiasmé
tout d'un coup on découvre les chiffres
la consommation en mai en juin ce parce
qu'ils sont très bons on a les recettes
de tva en août 15 à 2,5 milliards
supérieure à celle de 2019 puis ensuite
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des plans sociaux
qui se prépare et puis que l'épidémie
pourrait repartir donc nous allons
passer par des hauts et par débat par
des moments d'enthousiasmé par des
moments de découragement
je pense que la responsabilité politique
dans ces temps instable
c'est justement de faire preuve de
cohérence de stabilité et de vision à
long terme le problème de l'économie
française
aujourd'hui reste un problème d'offre de
formation une qualité de ses produits
d'innovation et c'est avec ce plan de
relance que nous répondrons à ces défis
merci monsieur le ministre pour exposé
très complet je vais passer maintenant
la parole au ministre délégué des
comptes publics jeu monsieur le ministre
délégué des comptes publics
à partir du moment où vous restez après
10h30 je vous suggère de passer
rapidement votre exposé parce que je lis
à 12 intervenant après le rapporteur
général et si on veut qu'elle vient donc
s'engage entre le ministre et de la
commission je pense qu'on reviendra
peut-être sur des sujets un précepteur
fatidique de 10h30
c'est bien noté monsieur le président
monsieur rapporteur général monsieur le
ministre à brno 3 3 points seulement et
par conséquence en style télégraphique
vous nous pardonnerez pour amener
quelques compléments quelques éléments
supplémentaires aux propos du ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
relance d'abord sur l'action
effectivement de l' architecture
budgétaire du plan de relance et de son
suivi
au delà des éléments indiqués par bruno
le maire alain fond nous allons aussi
mettre en place des comités territoriaux
de suivi dans chaque région en veillant
à ce que là aussi les services du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
soit partie prenante par l'intermédiaire
des dr philippe en particulier afin que
le pilotage territorial du plomb
souhaite aussi mises en oeuvre et que
nous puissions à l'échelle de chaque
région et en nous appuyant sur les
services départementaux veiller à ce que
les exécutions des actions engagées soit
bien au rendez-vous vous dire aussi
toujours sur l' architecture budgétaire
que nous aurons cette mission avec 3
programmes
les trois programmes correspondent aux
trois priorités du plomb et c'est un
point qui est important puisque au delà
du pilotage et des clauses de revoyure
est donc d'extinction de crédit évoqué
par bruno il ya un instant nous aurons
aussi la possibilité de travailler la
fongibilité des crédits et le fait de
n'avoir créé que trois programmes au
sein de la mission avec à chaque fois
comme responsable de programme le
ministre à l'économie des finances et
singulièrement la direction du budget
autorisant cad de clause de revoyure un
véritable redéploiement avec une
facilité de réaffectation des sommes
donc disposons avec toujours cette
volonté d'être à la fois ciblée efficace
et rapide et enfin en termes
d'architecturé les crédits relatifs à la
relance sont pour leur immense majorité
dans cette mission relance
avec la volonté d'ouvrir des
autorisations d'engagement de manière
massive en 2021 pour permettre
l'engagement et le décaissement rapide
des crédits vous trouverez aussi un
certain nombre de crédits dans le plfss
je pense notamment aux sommes consacrés
à l'investissement dans les
établissements hospitaliers ou
médico-sociaux et quelques-uns des
crédits sont déjà voté par le parlement
c'est notamment le cas de la prime pour
l'emploi des jeunes de la prime à la
conversion automobile ou encore d'autres
mécanismes relatifs aux appels à projets
sur la décarbonation deuxième point sur
lequel je veux m'arrêter un instant vous
faire écho aux propos de bruno le maire
la question de la compensation pour les
collectivités locales des baisses
d'impôts de production simplement pour
souligner est précisé que pour ce qui
concerne les régions cela représente une
diminution des impôts payés par les
entreprises de 7 milliards 2 mais nous
travaillons de compensation de 9
milliards cinq pour tenir compte des
dégrèvements déjà existants que l'état
finance auprès des régions et que la
fraction de tva est effectivement la
seule la méthode retenue pour garantir
une ressource dynamique au aux régions
pour ce qui concerne les collectivités
du bloc local
nous sommes sur la baisse de la tva b et
la cfe la tfpb pour 1750 milliards
d'euros et la cfe pour 1 milliard 540
millions d'euros et la piste que nous
envisageons que nous travaillons est un
prélèvement sur recettes de l'état qui
permettra d'avoir une compensation
dynamique en fonction de l'évolution des
bases de la partie a battu et comme cela
a été dit les communes et les
intercommunalités conserverons un
pouvoir de taux sur la fiscalité
foncière tel qu existantes et enfin
dernier point monsieur le président pour
ce qui concerne le financement du plomb
et son impact sur les finances publiques
et la trajectoire des finances publiques
en principe la réversibilité des
dépenses nous veillons scrupuleusement à
ce que un maximum des dépenses du plan
de relance sur des dépenses qui a un
caractère conjoncturel qu'elle ne soit
pas pérenne qu'elle ne soit pas
renouvelable
au delà des deux ont il ya quelques
exceptions à ce principe et la baisse
des impôts de production en est
évidemment de la même manière même si ce
n'est pas dans le plan d'eau
les dépenses salariales acceptée et
validée avec les accords figurent aussi
à caractère pérenne mais je précise
ça n'est pas dans le plan de relance
deuxième principe le taux de retour
maximal sur le financement par le plan
de relance européen jusqu'à 40 milliards
d'euros ce qui a pour conséquence de
renforcer notre engagement à ce que ce
soient des dépenses conjoncturelles et
non structurelle et deuxième conséquence
la poursuite des réformes structurelles
que l'on doit pouvoir mener pour
justifier et obtenir le taux de retour
maximal et cela m'amène troisième
conséquence ou un troisième engagement
la nécessité que nous avons des cas
extrêmement attentif pour ce qui
concerne les crédits rituel de la loi de
finances pour que notre maîtrise des
dépenses publiques soit la plus forte
possible de manière à ce que d'ici 2025
notre endettement puisse baisser sinon
la crédibilité de notre pays sur les
marchés sera durablement entamé et nous
ne pourrons faire face dans de
meilleures conditions aux besoins de
financement du pays
je termine par un mot mais je suis
convaincu que nous y reviendrons nous
avons à regarder et à voir je crois dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent à
la fois la trajectoire des finances
publiques et reno lemaire et moi-même
aurons certainement l'occasion de vous
présenter un projet de loi de
programmation pluriannuelle pour faire
en sorte que notre trajectoire des
finances publiques telles que assumée
revendiquée et dit publiquement soit
conforme à la réalité de ce que nous
connaissons
tant les évolutions depuis 2007 ont été
importantes
nous aurons aussi à réfléchir ensemble
je crois à des questions de gouvernance
de cantonnement dette et les meilleures
modalités et indicateurs possibles pour
retrouver le chemin du redressement des
finances publiques dans les temps qui
viennent
merci monsieur le ministre je suis passé
la parole au rapporteur général
merci messieurs les ministres j'ai
essayé d'être presqu'aussi synthétique
pays du soft avec d'abord pour vous dire
que je pense que nous sommes nombreux à
approuver l'idée d'une relance
je le sais l'avait souhaité d'ailleurs
peut-être plus en amont et il ya
peut-être eu un peu au départ un peu de
confusion dans la communication du
gouvernement puisque pendant une des
questions que j'avais posé là la
ministre
un espagnol une chine nous avait dit
nous aurons enfin août à plfr avec des
mesures qui viendront donc à l'examen du
parlement en septembre pour l'assemblée
nationale et en optant pour le pour le
sénat donc nous avons surtout peut-être
besoin de précisions par rapport aux
textes qui seront finalement la
traduction de ce plan de relance
notamment par un étonnement de
calendrier je regardais le document
l'instant je vois qu'il ya des appels à
projets qui circulent déjà
avec des délais très courts il faut
répondre avant fin octobre sur des
bâtiments publics alors même que le plan
n'aura pas encore été examiné par le
parlement
qu'est ce que vous avez peut-être sur
des précisions de calendrier pour savoir
si quels sont les films et disposition
qui relèveront soit du plf de fin
d'année donc de l'année 2021
est ce que ça donne de mesures seront
traduites dans un pfr de voeux de fin
d'année est ce qu'il y aura dans le
collectif de fin d'année traditionnel
des mesures applicables pour 2020 même
si je le dis je crois que nous
approuvons globalement l'idée d'un plan
de relance et je pense que nous sommes
également nombreux à partager autre
analyse monsieur le ministre
jean bruno le maire notamment d'un plan
de relance par l'investissement un pays
déficitaires comme la france des mesures
de relance de consommation elles
existent à travers notamment tout ce qui
était fermée taux de chômage partiel ne
doit pas évidemment encore accroître son
déficit nous sommes des sessions de très
différente des allemands de ce point de
vue donc si nous approuvons le plan
évidemment s'il ya sans doute de
questions et la première question
porte tout simplement sur peut-être
l'effet des mesures et notamment la
distinction entre les mesures de très
court terme et les mesures de plus long
terme 100 milliards d'euros c'est un
chiffre séduisant dans la réalité
qu'elle lit cage des mesures qui sont
vous êtes peut-être même infirmées mais
qui sont d'ores et déjà voté je pense
aux mesures sectorielles qu'on a déjà
voté 5 milliards 2 pour le plan des
plans sectoriels 2006 pour l'automobile
ce sont des mesures que dans sa majorité
le sénat à prouver puisque nous avons
voté les quatre plfr donc on our cycle
j'ai l'impression ascendante de mesures
d'ores et déjà voter et au delà
pouvez-vous nous peut-être un petit peu
précis entre ce qui relève du court
terme
j'ai pas la rénovation des bâtiments des
appels à projets est ce qui est du long
terme passe à l'hydrogène c'est très
séduisant je pense qu'on a sans doute
beaucoup d'espoir dans la transition
vers l'hydrogène mais on sait que c'est
des années des années de recherche et
donc la question porte très simplement
quelles seront les mesures un peu effet
immédiat qui auront un effet sur le
déficit soit de l'année 2021 soit
l'année 2022 qu'est-ce qu'on fait plus
précis dans ses 100 milliards qui sont
un agglomérat incombe un espèce
d'agrégats de différentes mesures
certaines est très court terme doit être
très long terme
deuxième question le volet fiscal le
volet fiscal
vous avez parlé de la fiscalité des
impôts de production on aura sans doute
d'un long débat puisque ça substitut
quand même des impôts relativement
stables pour les collectivités on y
mettra à la place des appeaux
conjoncturel parce que j'entends bien
monsieur le ministre que la tva est un
impôt dynamique en 2009 il ne l'était
pas et en ce moment il ne l'est pas donc
ça veut dire quand même les
collectivités qui n'ont pas droit
déficits vont être soumis à des
mécanismes des recettes conjoncturelles
sauf sur prévoit des mécanismes de
garantie mais notamment en 2009 2008
j'étais dans cette commission
comme un certain nombre je me souviens
et nous avions voté des mesures qui ont
montré leur efficacité je pense aux sur
amortissements
je pense au carry back qu'un par exemple
et ce volet fiscal ne semble pas figurer
à ce stade dans le dos le pelley et dans
le
depuis dans le document est ce qu'il est
prévu dans le plf qu'il y ait un volet
fiscal qui encourage notamment
l'investissement la relance est ma
dernière question porte sur des secteurs
spécifiques
je pense à ile-de-france mobilité
secteur qui nous à nous avions fait des
propositions elle n'avait il n'avait pas
été retenu au mois de juillet notamment
d'une avance remboursable de comptes
meilleure compensation est aujourd'hui
les chiffres sont aussi dramatique
le service fonctionne mais les recettes
de la ratp de la sncf ne sont pas là les
touristes ne sont pas là il est moins de
fréquentation des transports en commun
ni sa place ile-de-france mobilité en
situation qui est dramatique
il faudrait pas que l'investissement
soit la variable qui se permettent se
conduisent à arrêter tous les projets
d'investissement est-ce que donc
concrètement il y à un accord maintenant
avec l'ile-de-france mobilité quand
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous serons
évidemment très très vigilants et puis
une dernière question sectorielle il ya
des secteurs pour lequel on n'a pas
beaucoup de perspectives
je pense par exemple question bénéteau
voilà je pense que président bruno
retailleau dans cette région appeler
votre attention sur bénéteau 700 soit
emploi se pourrait qu'ils pourraient
être supprimés en france
bien sûr ils bénéficient des mesures de
chômage partiel
la question est simple des secteurs
comme ça où la france a une réelle
qualité des expertises mais la demande
est évidemment très très faible comment
continuer dordé des compétences des
savoir faire
ce qui serait ce qui serait dramatique
c'est évidemment qu'on ait des
licenciements des fermetures d usines
qui se traduisent par une perte de
compétences avec des salariés hautement
qualifiés donc c'est évidemment on ne
voit pas beaucoup de perspectives
aujourd'hui sur le secteur du nautisme
mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
secteurs voilà c'est pour les secteurs
les plus impactés comment continuer et
garder les compétences en attendant une
reprise qui malheureusement peut-être un
peu longue
merci beaucoup j'étais rapide en vous
remerciant et on nous approuvons le
principe du plan nous serons évidemment
particulièrement attentifs regardez
comment nous le traduire ont la parole
merci monsieur le président d'abord
merci pour rapporteur général albéric de
montgolfier pour ses propos
encourageants qui le pensons
particulièrement utile dans cette
période sur la première question
effectivement soyons totalement
transparents comme toujours on a regardé
plusieurs options
est-ce qu'on fait plusieurs textes à la
rentrée en mettant de les faire 4 et
puis une loi simple appoint certain
nombre de dispositifs moi j'ai plaidé
vigoureusement pour qu'il y ait un seul
texte que tout soit dans le plf par
souci de simplicité et de démocratie
parce que je pense que le plf c'est le
coeur battant de la vie politique
française c'est ce qui fait vivre notre
économie nos services publics et que sa
marque au grand choix de politique
économique donc mettre un plan de
relance en dehors du plf je trouvais ça
avait quelque chose de totalement
artificielle donc nous avons retenu
cette option de mettre le plan de
relance dans le projet de loi de
finances ça n'exclut pas d'avoir à
septembre de décisions qui sont prises
maintenant qui permettent d'anticiper
des projets qui mettent du temps à être
montés nous allons mettre par exemple un
milliard d'euros dans le plan de relance
sur des appels à projets pour
l'industrie toujours dans cette même
logique de relocalisation industrielle
nous sommes allés dans une magnifique
entreprise de pharmacie ces gens c'est
que présent la république la semaine
dernière ils ont investi pour créer de
nouveaux principes actifs de médicaments
et quand on re une entreprise comme
celle là on se dit que oui la pharmacie
a de l'avenir en france
et oui nous pouvons être aussi
compétitifs que les chinois parce que
nous avons des savoir faire
nous avons un niveau de technologie qui
sont de classe mondiale mais aujourd'hui
où le marché est moins porteur faire un
investissement de 20 ou 30 millions
d'euros pour l'entreprise comme ça c'est
très compliqué donc nous voulons
apporter des fonds tout de suite dont
auront débloqué 100 millions d'euros sur
le milliard pour financer des nouvelles
lignes
de production de certaines industries
qui n'ont pas le chiffre d'affaires
nécessaire pour investir tout de suite
et je n'hésite pas à le dire c'est de la
subvention publique directe voyez là
aussi le changement le logiciel c'est de
la subvention publique directe les
records on estime que cette entreprise
va se développer que dame en tout ça est
étudiée très soigneusement pour ne pas
soutenir des projets qui sera à perte
mais quand on a une belle industrie une
belle usine
un principe qui correspond à nos choix
politiques la souveraineté stratégique
qu'on met l'argent nécessaire et en anti
6 milliards d'euros deuxième exemple
lesaffre magnifique entreprise qui faire
la levure et qui est un des géants
mondial de la fermentation des processus
de fermentation qui sont extrêmement
porteur pour non seulement
l'agroalimentaire mais aussi pour la
santé
ils vont ouvrir deux nouvelles lignes de
production 150 millions d'euros chacune
400 emplois créés dans le nord ils ont
besoin d'argent tout de suite je
n'hésite pas dire on va leur apporter
l'argent
ce que quand vous visitez cette
entreprise et vous voyez le niveau
technologique de cette entreprise son
rayonnement mondial
et l'enjeu stratégique que ça représente
par rapport au seul concurrent dans le
domaine de la fermentation de levure les
chinois dans les heureux d'avoir une
entreprise de ce niveau là il faut la
soutenir on le fait et donc
effectivement je confirme qu'un certain
nombre de dépenses à engager maintenant
inscrite dans le plf façon à gagner du
temps sur l'effet court terme et long
terme c'est effectivement un sujet
absolument stratégique
toutes les mesures que nous avons prises
de soutien à la demande par exemple
l'industrie automobile a de chômage
partiel de confirmation de la baisse des
impôts je pense par exemple à la taxe
d'habitation auront des effets immédiats
sur la croissance après le plan de 100
milliards d'euros le plan
d'investissement et de relance doit
avoir un effet sur le plus long terme
nos objectifs sont de récupérer 4 points
de pib d'ici 2025
c'est un objectif qui est ambitieux
mais c'est un objectif qui est
atteignable et qui est à la portée du
tissu économique français
nous visons une réduction de 57 millions
de tonnes de co2 ce la durée de vie des
projets écologiques que nous avons
engagé et nous visons la création de
400000 emplois d'ici 2022
je confirme évidemment le chiffre de 160
mille emplois pour 2021 qui a été
annoncé par le premier ministre à tous
ceux qui disent que ce n'est pas
suffisant en termes d'emploi je rappelle
qu' il faut aussi comptabiliser tous les
emplois que nous aurons sauvé par le
chômage partiel n'est pas l'activité
partielle de longue durée
là je vous parle de la création
d'emplois je ne comptabilise pas tous
les emplois dont nous éviterons la
suppression grâce au chômage partiel et
grâce à l'activité partielle de longue
durée
voici les objectifs que nous nous sommes
fixés retrouvé quatre points de pipe
d'ici 2025 supprimé 57 millions de
tonnes de co2 supplémentaires soit la
durée de vie des projets écologiques et
créer 400 mille emplois d'ici 2022
s'agissant du volet fiscal nous avons
écarté effectivement le sur
amortissements parce que nous estimions
que la baisse d'impôts de production
était déjà un soutien très fort aux
entreprises le carry back en revanche
figure dans le plfr 3 donc une partie du
carry back figure dans le projet de loi
de finances numéro 3 que vous avez voté
en juillet un mot enfin sur bénéteau
j'ai été alerté par le président
retailleau
bénéteau est une magnifique entreprise
je les visite est à plusieurs reprises
s'est bien repris ce qui est dynamique
qui crée des bateaux qui ont une
réputation mondiale qu'un savoir faire
exceptionnel dans la fabrication dans le
design dans l'invention nautique
nous soutiendrons bénéteau il n'est pas
question de laisser partir un fleuron
français comme celui là les temps sont
difficiles les commandes ne sont pas là
il ya le chômage partiel y ait la paix
ld il ya d'autres types de soutien qui
peuvent être apportées mais il est
évident que sur ses fleurons français
nous apporterons un soutien nécessaire
et là je crois que c'est vraiment la
responsabilité des élus c'est ce coup
et pourtant général c'est ce qu'a fait
le président bono retailleau de nous
signaler partout sur le territoire des
fleurons industriels des fleurons
technologiques qui ne sont pas menacées
par ce qu'il n'aurait pas fait les
efforts d'adaptation nécessaire parce
qu'il n'aurait pas investi mais tout
simplement parce qu'il n'y a plus de
marché donc il faut les aider à passer
ce temps là et les aider à évoluer je
donne un deuxième exemple qui est très
cher à mon coeur on vous le savez c'est
le décolletage vallée de l'arve
décolletage cette tradition française
depuis la fin du 19e siècle
ces quinze mille emplois directs sur la
vallée de l'arve ils dépendent
totalement de deux secteurs l'industrie
automobile et l'industrie aéronautique
on leur a dit l'industrie automobile les
pièces mécaniques vont être moins
nombreuses dans les motos électriques
mettez vous sur l'aéronautique ils
investissent et il se met sur
l'aéronautique et le marché aéronautique
s'effondre pas laisser tomber le
décolletage dans la vallée de l'arve
quand il faut que nous trouvions des
moyens d'accompagner sur la durée un
certain nombre de secteurs industriels
comme cela où les entrepreneurs n'ont
pas démérité les salariés n'ont pas
démérité ils sont simplement victime
d'un effondrement conjoncturel
merci monsieur le ministre ces
précisions
merci monsieur le président de de
précision pour évidemment confirmer
qu'au delà des dispositions qui seront
votées en pelleve 2021 et bono maladie
l'objectif c'est 30% de décaissement et
donc de crédit paiement minimum au cours
l'année 2021 les dispositions votées
dans les plf air successifs notamment le
troisième garantissent le financement
des actions qui doivent être mises en
oeuvre sur la fin de l'année et si nous
devions mais à ce stade ce n'est pas
utile si nous devions profiter du plf de
fins de gestion pour tel ou tel
abonnement de crédit nous le ferions
pour garantir le bon financement de la
même manière sur les appels à projets
mentionnés par le rapporteur
nous avons ouvert bruno le maire a dit
l'appel à projets pour la rénovation des
bâtiments de l'immobilier d'état et nous
sommes sur des processus très rapide
puisque l'appel à projets sera fermé le
10 octobre
les projets seront sélectionnés entre
fin novembre et début décembre pour une
mise en oeuvre en 2020
et donc sur des dispositions 2021 sur
idf aime simplement un mot pour
confirmer qu'un accord est intervenu
entre le premier ministre et la
présidente de région valérie pécresse
nous avons dans cet accord qui fait
l'objet d'une convention arrêté le
principe d'une compensation des pertes
de recettes d'ile-de-france mobilité
pour un montant compris entre 1 milliard
sont et 1 milliard 400 millions d'euros
nous verrons début 2021 la réalité de la
perte de recettes
lorsque l'exercice sur un clos pour
arrêter définitivement le montant de
cette compensation et je signale qu'à la
suite du vote du plfr 3 il avait été
convenu du principe d'acompte
le premier raconte a été déversée
ile-de-france mobilité la présidente m'a
confirmé la disponibilité en termes de
trésorerie de la même manière je l'avais
confirmé que nous avions signé l'arrêté
permettant ce versement à hauteur de 425
millions d'euros ce qui permet de
garantir avec cet accord que la crise du
coc vide n'aura pas de conséquence sur
le prix pour les usagers et nous
l'espérons mais cela fait partie du
travail des discussions que nous avons
avec ile-de-france mobilité sur le
programme d'investissement de celui ci
mais la convention est signée entre le
premier ministre et valérie pécresse
très bien chaque collègue vous êtes d'où
gêne à voir des questions donc je vous
renvoie faire trois séries
concernant les questions posées je
commence par jean-françois du champ
après c'est ce qu'on fera
merci monsieur le président mes jolis
messieurs les ministres
j'ai quelques questions et je vous prie
messieurs les ministres de bien vouloir
excuser mon départ mais je suis comme
d'autres je dois jongler avec la sncf
qui réduit un petit peu son offre de
transport en commun pour rejoindre nancy
donc je n'aurai pas en direct votre
réponse quatre questions brèves smith
vous avez dit j'y suis sensible que le
premier sujet c'est est d'accélérer
finalement la transition écologique et
la dame carbo nation de l'économie et
d'en faire un sujet de rassemblement je
fais je forme un voeu c'est que nous
arrivions je veux juste rappeler que
jusqu'à maintenant ça beaucoup été un
sujet de division je veux parler des
bonnets rouges des gilets jaunes et des
phénomènes de zad
donc tout ce qui pourra aider est une
bonne chose simplement sur un aspect je
souhaiterais que vous
puissiez nous donner des éléments de
réponse sur tout ce qui concerne le les
efforts faits pour le dernier kilomètre
dont on parle beaucoup depuis 20 ans
j'aborde la évidemment tous les
problèmes de logistique en termes de
commerce et de centre ville puisque ça
ça a plusieurs avantages
c'est à la fois de lutter contre la
pollution mais également de rendre plus
efficace et plus fluide
la distribution des marchandises et
autant que la fluidité de la circulation
deuxième sujet le sujet de l'agriculture
qui me paraît être avec la présentation
qui a été encore fait part au sein
monsieur le ministre un angle mort vous
aborder la question agricole
principalement sous le volet
environnemental monsieur le ministre
vous avez exercé d'éminentes
responsabilité au ministère de la
culture
vous savez combien la culture française
je dirais même les agricultures
françaises sont en difficulté le revenu
est très faible
aujourd'hui pour beaucoup d'exploitants
la sécheresse les conditions météo les
effets de la pac les effets des accords
devant être signés actuellement
suspendue au niveau du commerce mondial
sont des sujets majeurs de souveraineté
alimentaire et je souhaite monsieur le
ministre que soit rappelé tous les
efforts qui ont été faits pour avoir de
la traçabilité et de la sécurité des
produits
la france mérite pour sur la culture
autre chose que de la grille bashing
troisième élément monsieur le ministre
c'est la question de l'europe l'europe
mobilise des fonds importants plus de
700 milliards
la france va bénéficier de 40 milliards
là où le de l'europe là par rapport à un
plan de mobilisation de 100 milliards
l'allemagne de 30 alors que l'allemagne
de 30 milliards européens alors qu'elle
mobilise 130 milliards pour quelle
raison monsieur le ministre cet accord
est intervenu sans finalement il soit
corrélé la participation des états au
regard de ce que l'europe donne puisque
finalement je suis moi partisans d'une
logique de donnant donnant avec des
efforts partagés sans qu'ils aient trop
de distorsion enfin
un sujet majeur monsieur le ministre dès
le début de la difficulté dans laquelle
nous détend travers la crise de
l'accueil de 19
j'avais interpellé ici même le
gouverneur de la banque de france sur le
sujet de l'épargné des ménages
parce que finalement on voit s'envoler
l'épargné des ménages dont une bonne
partie est facilitée ou provient des
efforts que l'état fait et donc vous
avez appelé à un rassemblement et bien
moi j'appelle aussi un rassemblement des
énergies et des finances parce que
finalement ce que l'état donne d'un côté
les français aujourd'hui peut-être faute
de visibilité le théorise je crois que
nous devons et j'attends des réponses à
ce sujet les sionistes trouver des
moyens originaux d'associer les français
par leur épargne à cet effort
exceptionnel que nous devons mobiliser
ensemble puisque finalement encore
l'état reste pour beaucoup
financé par celles et ceux qui apportent
leur contribution bien à la parole et à
michel clanet canevet merci monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres chers
collègues vous avez terminé votre propos
introductif monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances en évoquant
l'évolution des métiers
la délégation sénatoriale aux
entreprises a produit un rapport fargeas
juste à ce sujet il pourra être utile
pour bien appréhender cette question là
dans le plan de relance sont été évoqué
différents axes de développement il ya
notamment la question de l'habitat je me
pose la question de savoir si les deux
milliards d'euros dédiés à la transition
énergétique pour l'habitat privé seront
suffisants est ce que le la question de
l'abonnement subvention est vraiment le
meilleur moyen d'intervention ayant un
réel effet de levier ne faudrait-il pas
plutôt envisager un abondement du prêt à
taux zéro dont on connaît l'efficacité
pour ce qui concerne l'ensemble du
secteur du bâtiment
vous avez évoquées dans le plan de
relance la question du numérique est
absolument essentiel et on l'a aperçue
alors sans doute aperçu lors de la
période pour le sanitaire qu'on ne vient
de connaître
pour ce qui concerne la bretagne par
exemple nous avons un plan de fibrage à
l'abonné d'ici 2026 sans doute 2027 tous
les foyers
le secrétaire d'état au numérique notre
jour a dit que la france serait fibre
est intégralement d'ici 2025
est ce que des amendements pourraient
être tenues pour permettre d'anticiper
les programmes déjà lancés
que peuvent supporter les collectivités
c'est pour cela que s'est étalée dans le
temps est ce que la bande vendetta
permettra d'aller un peu plus vite
ensuite vous avez évoqué la question de
l'aéronautique effectivement c'est un
secteur extrêmement touchée nous avons
dans le finistère nous subissons je
dirais les conséquences de la
restructuration de du groupe air france
est notamment la suppression d'un site
aéronautique à morlaix historique quelle
mesure d'aménagement du territoire peut
tout envisager ne peut-on pas envisagée
dans le cadre des contreparties de
l'intervention de l'état octroyée à air
france est justifiée d'ailleurs que des
compensations en terme d'aménagement des
territoires puissent être fait c'est à
dire que le siège social par exemple
d'europe puissent aller à morlaix parce
que finalement à nantes il ya une telle
diversité d'activités dans cette
métropole que kylie à 250 emplois en
plus haut au moins ça ne changera rien
tandis qu à morlaix l'impact est tout à
fait significatif et puis je voudrais
conclure monsieur messieurs les
ministres en évoquant la question du
transport maritime qui est absolument
essentiel parce que si l'aéronautique
souffre terriblement le transport
maritime aussi nous avons la chance
d'avoir en france une compagnie maritime
qui est initié par les paysans qui est
la brittany ferries et qui est essentiel
pour je dirais le désenclavement d'une
partie de la france dans partie nord
dans son entier les relations avec la
grande-bretagne l'irlande et l'espagne
et il se trouve que si le secteur
aéronautique est touché le secteur
maritime mais aussi considérablement
d'une part bien sûr par les mesures de
quarantaine décidées par le gouvernement
britannique mais aussi dans la
perspective du brésil est encore face à
la concurrence internationale à laquelle
est affronté je veux dire par là que les
concurrents bénéficient d'exonérations
de charges sociales
est-ce que l'on peut envisager d'aller
d'abord un peu plus loin parce que le
temps de retour à meilleure fortune
ira au delà de la fin d'année donc
est-ce qu'on peut envisager par ce qui
concerne le chômage partiel une
prolongation dans le temps premièrement
et puis deuxièmement est-ce que des
mesures complémentaires de type
exonération des charges sociales leur
permettant de retrouver la compétitivité
pourrait être envisagée pour que cette
compagnie demeure une compagnie
française
merci yvon collin
oui merci je le demande un raccourci
véritablement dans la mesure du possible
autrement je n'arrivais d'être aussi
messieurs les ministres à bien des
égards le plan de relance ait fait le
pari de la reprise de l'offre ce qui
suppose un déblocage de l'epargne que
nos concitoyens ont accumulé un bas de
laine
monsieur le ministre de l'ordre de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards
est-ce que vous avez des signaux
concernant une reprise nette de la
consommation alors que la confiance des
ménages doit faire face avec un horizon
de milliers de faillite attendue et un
chômage qui devrait toucher en fin
d'année 9,5 pour cent de la population
active
deuxième question dans son allocution en
français au mois de mars dernier le
président de la république déclaré que
la pandémie révélé la nécessité de
placer des biens et des services en
dehors de la loi de marché comment le
plan de relance aborde cet objectif
sachant que les aides telles que les
baisses d impôts de production ne sont
pas conditionnées et que l'emploi public
n'est pas mobilisée j'ajoute
l'inquiétude des maires concernant les
compensations consécutif à cette baisse
des coûts de production
que répondez-vous aux maires qui sont
particulièrement inquiets merci monsieur
le ministre si nous allons terminer par
nathalie goulet pour cette première
série de questions aux ministres
oui mais c'est les ministres présidents
messieurs les ministres merci pour
ce détail de ce détail du plan sachant
que la situation est tellement inédites
qu'on a bien évidemment conscience des
efforts qui sont faits moi j'ai trois
questions la première sur la
territorialisation dont vous avez parlé
pensez vous un guichet unique parce que
les régions les départements et toutes
les collectivités essaye de renforcer
l'aide aux entreprises comment
comptez-vous fluidifier ou au moins à
homogénéiser cette territorialisation
avec les banques des territoires je
présume la bpi enfin qu est ce que vous
pourriez nous donner quelques détails
sur la territorialisation ensuite ma
question et lors du débat sur le palais
faire 3 n'a pas pu voter dans tous les
cas aménager le chômage partiel avec une
lutte contre la fraude aux ex hanté et
non pas ex post
sylvie vermeille aurait voulu vous posez
la question elle est aussi parti à la
commission qu'ovide donc quelles sont
les mesures que vous entendez prendre à
la fois pour répondre au rapport de la
cour des comptes sur la fraude fiscale
mais également aux questions de fraude
au chômage partiel et j'en aurai terminé
en tant que rapporteur des engagements
financiers de l'état
en vous demandant s'il était possible en
tous les cas si le gouvernement était
d'accord pour qu'on commence la cession
par un débat sur les engagements
financiers parce que finalement le débat
sur les engagements financiers va
conditionner notre notre liberté
d'action pour pour cette relance merci
bien merci pour vos questions vous
transmettrai mes réponses aux sénateurs
us ont soit transition écologique
je pense que met le doigt sur quelque
chose de très juste
la transition écologique ne doit pas
devenir un motif de conflit entre les
français elle doit être au contraire un
motif de rassemblement je pense que nous
avons eu suffisamment d'expérience au
cours des dernières années avec le
bonnet rouge avec gilet jaune pour
montrer que si nous prenons des
décisions trop brutale trop vite
la transition écologique peut créer des
conflits profonds dans le pays alors
même qu'une immense majorité de français
souhaite que nous accélérions donc il
faut trouver une autre méthode
c'est la méthode que nous avons retenu
kessel de la consultation la plus large
possible
c'est l'objectif de la convention
citoyenne que j'ai rencontrés avec
barbara pompili il ya quelques semaines
et puis c'est les discussions avec
toutes fédérations qui sont concernés
canton en bretagne on voit un certain
nombre de représentants du bâtiment ou
surtout des travaux publics pour les
très petites entreprises de travaux
publics qui se sentent pénalisés par les
évolutions fiscales sur le gazole
routier ou sur l'utilisation des engins
de chantier il faut comme je lé fais les
recevoir
apporter des solutions et ouvrir des
perspectives pas se contenter de dire
circulez ya rien à voir
et on maintient notre décision très ça
ne marche pas on a essayé c'est
inefficace et ça crée des conflits
moi je tiens à ce que la transition
écologique soit un facteur de
rassemblement entre les français et ça
demande beaucoup d'écouté beaucoup de
travail pour y parvenir
la deuxième chose à mon sens pour eux
que cet objectif nous rassemble c'est
qu'on soit clair sur la stratégie
personne n'a la vérité révélée je le
redis mais la responsabilité politique
c'est de faire les choix qu'ils soient
claires nous ne croyons pas avec ce
gouvernement à la boue à la décroissance
et nous pensons que la transition écolo
iq ce n'est pas moins de prospérité pour
les français - de technologies moins de
savoir scientifique moins de médicaments
ou de thérapie de qualité c'est
exactement l'inversé
donc nous ne pensons pas que la
décroissance soit la solution pour
garantir la transition écologique et il
vaut mieux poser le débat sereinement
parce que je pense qu'en faisant preuve
de clarté on convainc davantage nous
nous croyons à une croissance décarbonée
nous ne croyons pas à des croissances
s'agissant de l'agriculture là je ne
peux pas laisser dire que j'étais un
angle mort du plan de relance
je viens de normandie de ministre de
l'agriculture s'est beaucoup battu pour
qu'il ya un volet agricole qui soit très
important dans le plan de relance qui
représente 1,2 milliard d'euros ce qui
est une somme évidemment importante avec
des projets très concrets je pense
notamment au renforcement de
l'indépendance de la france de la
production de produits bio il est
complètement anormal que nous ayons une
telle explosion de la consommation de
produits bio dans notre pays et qu'on ne
soit pas indépendant en matière de
production bio donc nous allons
continuer à soutenir fiscalement la
production bio en france
deuxième exemple très concret la
rénovation des abattoirs nous mettons
250 millions d'euros sur la rénovation
des abattoirs ça ça me parait des
projets très concrets et très utile
s'agissant de l'épargné et la
thésaurisation par les français je pense
qu'on a tous conscience du problème 85
milliards d'euros qui ont déjà été mis
de côté par les français tout simplement
parce que ils voient venir des temps
difficiles qui se demandent si leur
gamin va arriver à trouver un emploi et
qui se disent si mon fils ou ma fille
aînée qui a 22 23 ans trouvent pas
d'emploi elle va rester chez moi ou
enfin là que je lui paye son loyer va
falloir que je lui paye sa nourriture
c'est normal que les gens on met de
l'argent de côté
je pense que nous partageons tous les
mêmes inquiétudes
et ils ont tous la même réaction qu'elle
se dit on va mettre un peu d'argent de
côté
moi je veux redire à quel point le
cercle vertueux c'est celui qui va
amener les français à consommer à
investir dans l'économie française et à
participer au redémarrage de notre
économie
donc nous le faisons et des incitations
entre mais 7000 euros d'incitation sur
l'achat d'un véhicule électrique ça
marche
les gens se disent sera pas tout le
temps j'investis sera bien durables et
on a vu la consommation de biens
durables avaient fortement augmenté au
cours des derniers mois c'est moins vrai
pour la consommation courante
il faut le faire aussi en offrant des
produits attractifs c'est ce qu'on a
fait avec le pays or c'est ce que nous
faisons avec l'assurance vie avec des
produits qui vont financer les pme
françaises et c'est ce que nous allons
faire avec les obligations convertibles
ou les prêts participatifs qui seront
dans des fonds qui permettront de
financer l'économie française
donc nous avons mis sur pied nous allons
continuer à développer des produits qui
permettront aux épargnants français de
financer les pme et l'économie française
michel canevet ce que les subventions
sont ce qu'il ya de plus efficace
le taux zéro effectivement fonctionne
bien mais ma prime rénove fonctionne
très bien et si on s'est appuyé sur ma
prime annoncé que ce qu'on observe le
cours des derniers mois c'est que quand
vous donner jusqu'à 20000 euros
des directs les ménages qui rénovent
leurs bâtiments
c'est exactement comme la prime à 7000
euros pour les véhicules électriques ça
marche remarquablement bien donc c'est
très efficace
je rappelle que nous avons aussi décidé
de simplifier ma prime rénove
d'abord en ouvrant à tous les ménages
qui ne recevront pas la même chose
évidemment en fonction de leurs revenus
et en faisant deux innovations majeures
ma prime rénove sera accessible pour les
syndics de copropriété comme on veut
faire des rénovations globales
si vous avez votre appartement et que
vous êtes dans un immeuble avec cet
appartement
si vous rénovez uniquement vos portes et
vos fenêtres se sera pas efficace
mais évidemment on n'allait pas à
rénover la façade de tout l'immeuble où
les combles de tout l'immeuble
à la place des autres propriétaires donc
là nous allons autoriser les syndics de
copropriété avoir accès à ma prime
rénove pour faire cette rénovation
globale qui actera les façades et les
combles des immeubles nous réfléchissons
même à une simplification des décisions
des syndics de copropriété pour
accélérer ces rénovations globales
deuxième innovation les propriétaires
bailleurs vont être éligible au sieam
imprime rénove dire que quelqu'un qui a
pour compléter sa retraite
acheter un studio qui le loue jusqu'à
présent il n'était pas éligible à la
prime rénove
demain il sera éligible à bas prix mme
reno sous conditions d'ailleurs qu'il
baisse ensuite son loyer donc là c'est
un cercle extraordinairement vertueux on
rénove le bâtiment c'est bon pour
l'environnement et on a en plus une
baisse de loyer pour la personne qui
aura bénéficié ma prime rénove sur la
fibre est ce qu'il faut aller plus vite
oui moi je suis très attaché à ce que
nous développions la 5g rapidement je
vois là aussi les inquiétudes ça rejoint
la question de jean françois husson et
tout à l'heure mais on a fait deux
enquêtes une en septembre notre tiendra
en janvier notamment être l'un de cesse
donc sur les conséquences pour la santé
nous étudions ça de manière très
sérieuse et quand je dis nous c'est pas
nous aider des organismes qui sont
totalement indépendants mais sans la
salle g ou ne répondrait pas aux besoins
médicaux des territoires les plus
reculés de fans disons les choses comme
elles sont enfin tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont des avocats de la
décroissance qui refuse à 5 g et qui
disent que ça doit bénéficier amazon
c'est faux ça va aussi bénéficier les
réplications la vie courante absolument
essentiels comme la santé dans les zones
rurales
donc si nous voulons accélérer cela
c'est aussi parce que ça bénéficie à
tous les français dans leur vie
quotidienne
si vous voulez une usine qui s'installe
près de chez vous avec 20 salariés mais
qu'a besoin d'envoyer ses plans partout
à travers la planète
si vous n'êtes pas la 5g vous en voyez
pas les plans dans des délais qui soient
suffisamment rapide et donc vrai pas
votre routine qui s'installe faut que
les choix soient claires devant les
français moi je suis favorable au
déploiement rapide de la 5g pas
simplement pour les usages internet ou
autres pas simplement pour les usages
qui peuvent être récréatif mais pour les
usages de santé pour les usages
industriels pour les usages d'emploi
sans lesquels il n'y aura pas de
développement de tous les territoires en
france pour tous ceux qui sont attachés
comme vous et comme moi au développement
de tous les territoires français et qui
refusent
fatalité des déserts français la 5g est
une opportunité
s'agissant l'aéronautique et de morlaix
nous suivons la situation de très près
j'ai demandé à air france de proposer
des options aux salariés et d'avoir une
stratégie qui permette aux sites de
morlaix de voir comment est-ce que son
avenir peut se construire je ne
satisferait pas d'une réponse consiste à
dire voilà c'est fini on passe à autre
chose
de manière plus générale et je ne vise
pas du tout air france en disant cela
mais je vois toutes les questions que
vous posez indirectement sur la question
des entreprises nous voyons qu'il y a
beaucoup de plans sociaux qui sont en
préparation qu'il ya les entreprises qui
sont menacés de faillite
il ya des plans sociaux qui sont
nécessaires parce que ils vont permettre
à l'entreprise de rebondir de retrouver
des marges de manoeuvre est donc de
survivre à cette crise et de sortir plus
forte de la crise économique et puis il
y à d'autres plans sociaux qui sont des
plans sociaux d'aubaine
ces plans sociaux d'aubaine ne sont pas
acceptables et nous ne les laisserons
pas passer et nous emploierons tous les
moyens qui sont à la disposition du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
pour refuser ces plans sociaux d'aubaine
la crise économique doit mener chacun
faire preuve de sens des responsabilités
et pas profité de la situation pour
engager des plans sociaux qui ne
seraient pas indispensables pour que
l'entreprise puisse rebondir ne voulons
pas de ces plans sociaux d'aubaine je
vois se profiler par exemple à belfort
j'ai dit un certain nombre de
propositions qui ne me paraissent pas
tous correspondre aux engagements qui
ont été pris par ji nous veillerons à ce
que jy respecte ses engagements et que
le partenariat seront construits avec
les salariés de ji avec la direction de
gee et avec l'état
puis se poursuit sur de bonnes bases
et j'aurai l'occasion d'appeler le
président de gilles aricle très
prochainement pour lui dire nous avons
bien travaillé ensemble bien travailler
avec les représentants des salariés bien
travailler pour garantir l'avenir du
site de belfort
il y a les difficultés ça peut amener
certaines décisions mais certainement
pas des décisions d'aubaine
il faut que les choses soient claires
entre nous et je souhaite que nous
puissions conserver la qualité de ce
partenariat avec 10 comme avec toutes
les autres entreprises en france ce qui
suppose que chacun fasse preuve de sens
des responsabilités
s'agissant de teddy ferries et déjà
indiqué nous sommes prêts à soutenir le
trafic transmanche
soyons honnêtes les albres excite plus
la crise du grenat virus donc pour tout
le trafic transmanche ses 75 à 80 %
d'activité en moins moi j'ai besoin de
voir clair dans les comptes
j'ai besoin que chacun fasse preuve de
transparence totale et nous aiderons
pour trouver des solutions de long terme
au trafic transmanche il est vital pour
la bretagne
il est vite elle aussi pour la normandie
yvon collin
s'agissant de la consommation donc nous
avons effectivement une reprise de la
consommation avec un retour de la
consommation à un niveau proche d'avant
crise - 4 % en juillet c'est après tout
près de ce qu'était la consommation en
juillet 2019 et -2% en août on se
rapproche encore plus du niveau de
consommation en août avec une fois
encore des recettes de tva qui sont
bonnes
donc nous sommes dans la bonne direction
ce que je veux dire aux français nous
sommes dans la bonne direction et nous
allons y arriver et il faut pas se
laisser décourager par le moindre
incident qui va survenir un moment ou un
autre il y aura forcément des trous
d'air forcément des moments plus
difficiles
mais la direction est la bonne et une
fois encore je me donne deux ans pour
que nous retrouvions le même niveau de
développement
nathalie goulet enfin sur
la territorialisation des aides oui et
d'indispensables et nous allons nous
appuyer sur les préfets les sous-préfets
la relance sur la bpi qui fait un
travail remarquable dans les territoires
je vois caisse des dépôts et
consignations qui va avoir la
responsabilité de la mise en place des
6000 foncière je l'espère 10000 demain
pour que tout ce plan soit
territorialisées je donne juste
l'exemple de ces foncière parce que je
pense que c'est très important vous
voyez tous dans vos villes dans vos
communes de des commerces qui ferment et
plus d'activités certainement pas été
digitalisées qu'est ce que c'est la
réponse un aider la digitalisation de
ces commerces que tous ceux qui ne sont
pas des gîtes alizés ne pourrons pas
survivre ce n'est pas de site internet
veut pas vendre à distance alors que
l'épidémie reste aujourd'hui vivace elle
vous ne pouvez pas vous en sortir que
les clients ne viennent pas donc il faut
investir sur les digital isation des
commerces de proximité
nous le faisons et nous étions plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros dessus
avec notamment soutien de la bpi et la
deuxième chose c'est la possibilité de
racheter des fonds de commerce et rénové
faire la rénovation énergétique parfois
les rassembler tout ça c'est la caisse
des dépôts qui va le prendre à sa charge
puis ensuite loué un tarif préférentiel
pour faire revenir des commerçants en
centre-ville
troisième volet de cette politique s'est
évité le saccage de terres agricoles ou
l'emploi de terres agricoles qui sont
évidemment ce qui est plus facile pour
construire des grands centres
commerciaux
je pense que si on a les trois volets de
cette politique globale on peut réussir
à territorialisée le plan en soutenant
le commerce de proximité
enfin sur la fraude sociale et je le
serai évidemment olivier du soft
complété en m'excusant de devoir vous
quitter
maintenant le rapport la cour des
comptes est claire nous voulons durcir
notre dispositif de contrôle est il de
sanctions contre la fraude sociale
elle est inacceptable en temps ordinaire
elle est révoltante en temps de crise
nous allons tirer toutes les
conséquences du rapport de la cour des
comptes
je vous remercie si c'est vrai monsieur
le président mais si je ne parvenais pas
à ce moment là la question de dimont
colin sur la question des compensations
et des deux collectivités resterait sans
réponse et ce serait certainement
dommage
juste un nom pour dire qu'en plus de ce
que vient de dire bruno le maire sur la
fraude
nous allons durcir les dispositifs nous
allons aussi utiliser les dispositifs
existants et aujourd'hui tous nos
services sont mobilisés notamment pour
lutter contre la fraude au chômage
partiel comme la fraude un peu moindres
dans son envergure au fonds de
solidarité
et quand je dis tous les services y
compris des services comme traque fin de
manière à retracer des flux qui n'aurait
pas lieu d'être
et si plusieurs dizaines de procédures
sont en cours
comprenez que le secret de l'enquète en
la matière nous interdit de donner leur
teneur mais en tout cas soyez assurés
que nous sommes vigilants et nous avons
mis à profit cette crise et ce contrôle
nouveau sur le chômage partiel explose
pour améliorer les modes de
communication et des transmissions
d'informations entre nos services
enquête et un certain nombre de services
comme l' agence des services de paiement
de manière à ce que nous puissions aussi
intervenir avant le paiement à
d'éventuels fraudeurs sur la question
des ressources des collectivités locales
très rapidement je répète ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure et je complète d'un
mot d'abord pour garantir le fait que la
compensation sera par une fraction de
tva pour les régions et avec un
caractère sur long terme et je sais que
nous sommes dans une année de crise qui
est un caractère dynamique et nous
allons le faire sur la base de la
recette constatée entre 2019 2020 et les
discussions avec les régions ont abouti
pour la compensation de la tp b la c
feu de précision la première pour dire
que le psr prélèvements sur recettes que
j'ai évoquées qui sera dynamique en
fonction de l'évolution des bases sera
calculé sur la base des valeurs
locatives de 2020 et le taux de 2020 ce
qui est rassurant en termes de planches
et de compensation et la deuxième
précision pour dire que d'ores et déjà
la cgt fait l'objet d'un mécanisme de
plafonnement à 3% que si une entreprise
devrait contribuer théoriquement au delà
de ce plafond de 3%
c'est un dégrèvement que l'état assure
pour garantir à la collectivité
l'intégralité de sa recette est donc un
des mécanismes retenu au delà de la
division par deux des valeurs locatives
c'est l'abaissement du plafond de 3 à 2%
avec l'application d'un mécanisme de
dégrèvements qui existe déjà
ce qui signifie qu'en termes de
compensation nous sommes sur un modèle
qui a fait ses preuves pour les
collectivités dans le cadre de ce
plafonnement
je précise enfin que indépendamment de
cette compensation des recettes fiscales
à venir pour les impôts de production la
confiance avec les collectivités se
bâtit aussi sur ce qui se passe c'est ce
qui s'est passé je renvoie à la
stabilité en volume global on enveloppe
de balle des dotations de fonctionnement
je saisis l'occasion pour d'ores et déjà
indiqué au sénat que le plf 2021
renouvellera les reconduire à cette
stabilité des dotations de
fonctionnement mais aussi la stabilité
des dotations d'investissement pour ce
qui concerne ile-de-france mobilité j'ai
répondu albéric de montgolfier avec
l'accord conclu et je précise de
dernière chose pour l'application des
mécanismes de garantie de recettes que
vous avez adopté dans le cadre du plfr 3
pour ce qui concerne les régions les
départements pardonnez moi pour ce qui
concerne les départements en avance
remboursable sur les dmt au fait l'objet
d'un calcul d'acompte à l'initiative des
présidents de départements qui ont
jusqu'à fin septembre le 21 pour être
précis pour déposer cette demande
d'acompte en lien avec mode et des fip
pour ce qui concerne les communes et les
intercommunalités qui font l'objet d'un
mécanisme de compensation pour garantir
un niveau minimum de recettes domaniales
et fiscales sur la moyenne 2017 2019 ce
sont nos services des finances publiques
qui vont estimer la perte de recettes
qui vont proposer un acompte aux
collectivités et comme pour les
départements comme pour idée est faible
le début de l'année 2000 21 sera
l'occasion de la régularisation
mais je le dis parce que
je pense que c'est important pour les
maires notamment il n'y a pas de
démarche à faire ce sont nos services
qui vont estimer s'il ya une recette
domaniale et fiscale inférieure à la
moyenne que nous avons mentionné bien en
date amant que la deuxième série de
questions avec roger karoutchi ce sera
jean françois rapin après sophie calle
paulhan et jean claude requier très bien
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
deux observations rapide et deux
questions rapides deux observations
rapide
l'accord sur idfm mobilité n'est que le
rattrapage de l'erreur qu'a été celle
commise par le rapporteur général du
budget à l'assemblée nationale
il ya quelques semaines donc j'espère
réellement que cet accord sera respectée
traduit réellement concrètement pour que
ce soit pas les 5 millions d'usagers
jour des transports publics qui
représentent 60% des utilisateurs des
transports publics en france qui paye la
différence
deuxième observation j'entends bien les
9 milliards et demi de compensation pour
les collectivités des 17,3 milliards de
de pertes de recettes
j'entends bien l'explication technique
j'espère que à l'arrivée il y aura
réellement une compensation qui fasse en
sorte que les collectivités s'en sortent
parce qu'elles ont pris beaucoup de
charges supplémentaires avec la crise qu
vide et et sincèrement ils sont un
exemple donc je suis moins rassurés
quand on me dit il ya d'abord la perte
de recettes et ensuite la compensation
dans une situation déjà très difficile
donc je j'espère que techniquement tout
ça pourrait se faire correctement
deux questions rapides j'avais déjà dit
au mois de mai à bruno le maire je suis
admiratif devant le fait d'avancer sur à
l'époque lé ps fr / comme si nous étions
non pas en fin de crise mais pas loin et
que ça y est on était sortis du
confinement on reprenait tout allait
aller pour le mieux je disais déjà un
vous n'êtes pas à l'abri présente plus
aujourd'hui d'une deuxième vague ou en
tout cas
d'une alerte sanitaire tellement forte
que vous pourrez raconter ce que vous
voulez il y aura des conséquences
économiques sociales beaucoup plus
lourde que ce qu'on avait prévu
et je ne vois pas pourquoi aujourd'hui
je serai rassuré de ce côté là et est ce
que vous ne croyez pas c'est la question
est ce que vous ne croyez pas qu'en
réalité vous peut-être à bercy vous avez
une maîtrise de ce que vous prévoyez
mais c'est une maîtrise rationnelle or
l'irrationnel dominent les gens ne
veulent pas d épargne et non pas
seulement parce qu'ils se demandent si
leur fils aura un emploi mais simplement
parce qu'ils se demandent quelle va être
la situation sanitaire demain pour eux
pour tous quels que soient les
situations familiales et je suis un peu
éberlués de voir dans ce gouvernement
un côté rationnel clair précis à bercy
et un côté irrationnel pour ne pas dire
totalement aléatoire de la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
si vous ne rendez pas confiance aux
français sur la crise sanitaire
vous ne vendrez pas français confiance
dans l'investissement dans le départ et
dans le fait d'intervenir
ça n'est pas possible et là on a
l'impression qu'à une cassure entre la
gestion de la crise sanitaire et la
gestion à terme de l'économie française
donc comment faites vous pour faire en
sorte demain de rendre confiance aux
français ça ne passe pas que par
l'aspect économique
ça passe par le fait d'avoir une
politique sanitaire crédible qui soit
acceptable pour tous et deuxième
question presque ironique vous lancer un
plan de relance qui va par définition
durer quelque temps
quel est le lien envisagé avec le
commissariat général au plan monsieur
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'avais trois questions et puis
je terminerai par une remarque que vous
pourrez juger à mon avis sympathique jeu
sur les trois questions de ont déjà
obtenu une réponse largement efficace
néanmoins j'insiste sur sur ces faits le
premier c'était bien sûr la question du
transport maritime et de brittany
ferries mais tout à leurs ministres le
maire a évoqué deux régions la normandie
la bretagne mais je rappelle aussi qu'il
y a les autres france avec un trafic
transmanche jeu très très important et
ça n'est pas oublié mais en tout cas le
point sur brittany ferries est essentiel
parce que on sait très bien que perdre
80 % de son activité avec un mélange est
un amalgame entre le break site bien sûr
la crise du coc vides sont sont des
points très très néfaste le deuxième
point c'était celui de l'industrie
nautique
il a été évoqué sur bénéteau bien sûr on
a entendu ce matin dans une grande radio
nationale les propos de fabien métayer
qui est délégué général de la fédération
des industries nautiques avec cette
inquiétude forte puisque l'industrie
nautique sa touche quand même 50 mille
emplois directs et près de cent mille
près de 100 me dans l'indirect donc au
delà de bénéteau bien sûr il y aura des
efforts à faire mais le ministre a
répondu le troisième point est beaucoup
plus technique et il concerne
l'articulation entre le plan de relance
national bien sûr on a des plans de
relance de des plans de relance
régionaux dont je ne doute pas que vous
les suivez de près et puis on a un grand
plan de relance qui les plans de relance
européens
moi je voudrais savoir comment vont
s'articuler à la fois et au moins le
plan de relance européen avec le plan de
relance national
d'autant qu'on sait que dans les 100
milliards injectés 40 milliards
viendront déjà de l'europe
donc il est important de savoir comment
cette articulation à se faire si elle
sera fluide qui gérera les fonds toutes
ces questions
non pas encore de réponse et pourtant
c'est important parce que la déclinaison
régionale est forte aussi et on a besoin
de ces réponses au niveau régional puis
ma ma remarque que vous pourrez juger
sympathique monsieur le maire a parlé
tout à l'heure de de sa croyance forte
en du déploiement de la 5g notamment
pour la santé pour eux les problèmes de
désertification
moi j'ai une proposition à vous faire
pour une fois sur une nouveauté
numérique sur sur une innovation
numérique
commençons le déploiement tard le milieu
rural et tout ira bien merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
écoutez je regrette que vous nous le
maire soit partie parce que j'étais très
étonné de sa manière de deux pauses et
la recherche du consensus sur les
questions environnementales et donc par
la suite il a quelque peu excusez moi le
terme est vraiment caricaturer ce que
peuvent être les écologistes qui
voudrait selon lui - de prospérité moins
de technologie - de recherche médicale
je crois que là on est vraiment sur le
chemin d'un débat à la recherche d'un
consensus
bon je crois effectivement que les
questions qui sont posées sur le plan de
relance par rapport aux contreparties
environnementales sont réels et que les
attentes des français en la matière sont
très importantes et qu'il convient d'y
répondre autrement que de 7 que de cette
façon sur le plan de relance précisément
et je crois que c'est une constante par
rapport aux différents plfr que nous
avons eu à débattre et à adopter ces
derniers mois il y à un impensé il ya
des oubliés ce sont les personnes en
situation de précarité
effectivement bruno le maire le dit
soutenir la demande par le travail mais
à tous ceux qui sont confrontés à des
carrières de précarité qui ont des
grandes difficultés par rapport au fait
à l'accès à l'emploi
et bien cela ils sont oubliés dans ce
plan puisque on a uniquement une très
faible part 0 10% si jeune si je ne
m'abuse avec des mesures allocation
rentrée scolaire et aides pour les pour
les tickets restaurants pour les
étudiants qui ne couvre pas l'immense
difficultés que traverse aujourd'hui
un très très grand nombre de français il
ya quand même 9 millions de français qui
sont dans la grande pauvreté et ce sont
eux qui sont touchés directement
fortement terriblement par cette crise
et à auquel on ne donne aucun aucun
signe réel
alors c'est vrai il ya des français qui
épargnent puis à des français qui
souffrent parce que sont bien moins de
pouvoir épargner puisqu'il ne finisse
pas les fins de mois et je crois que sur
ce plan de relance oui il ya des grands
oubliés et c'est un impensé parce qu'on
parle de 800 ch mille chômeurs en plus
et là j'ai entendu bruno le maire qui
disait 400000 emplois créés d'ici deux
villes 2022
le premier ministre qui disait 160 mille
emplois d'ici 2020 p a en tout cas la
marche est très haute
et là je crois qu'il ya beaucoup d'
oublier deuxième point et après je mange
mende arrêterez là c'est la question
bien sûr de cette mesure pérenne qui est
né dans le plan de relance et vous allez
baisser les impôts à nouveau pour les
entreprises de 10 milliards par an donc
ça veut dire quand même une facture pour
les autres à suivre à partir de 2022
sans compter qu'en même que déjà les
baisses de recettes liées à la
suppression progressive de la taxe
d'habitation ne sont pour l'instant
n'était pas compenser on ne savait pas
exactement comment les choses allaient
s'organiser nouvelles baisses d'impôts
sans contrepartie encore une fois et
sans ciblage alors même qu'on sait que
cela que cela ne marche pas tout
simplement
donc moi je crois que cette politique de
l'offre et ce refus de voir que la
demande s'est pas seulement pour
satisfaire des besoins superflus mais
une relance de par l'adp par la demande
pourrait satisfaire des besoins
essentiels
je crois que vous passez à côté de ce
plan de relance sur les questions qui
sont à mon avis très importante pour les
françaises et les français qui ont
besoin non seulement ça a été dit de
pouvoir se projeter un peu dans l'avenir
et dans l'avenir je crois qu'ils
demandent davantage de justice alors
dernière question il y à un certain
nombre de hauts dirigeants de personnes
qui ont des très hauts revenus qui ont
dit bah nous nous sommes prêts à payer
un impôt exceptionnel vous ne relevez
pas la proposition
merci
le podium ministre d'abord je dois dire
que je soutiens tout à fait ce plan de
relance par l'investissement qui est
nécessaire et s'il obtient peu de
critiques le point de vue applications
et spectre d'applications
certains le trouvent trop sétif et
d'autre le trop trop large on parle de
saupoudrage à la vérité entre les deux
des questions simplement rapide
le plan prévoit 3 milliards d'euros pour
le renforcement des fonds propres des
pme
est ce vraiment suffisant alors que les
études économiques y estime les besoins
à plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'euros sachez en outre que le cully du
dispositif pellieux les prêts garantis
par l'état
atteignez cet été un peu 816 milliard
d'euros et qu'il faut voir que
l'entreprise rembourse cette montagne de
dettes
deuxième question s'agissant des
allègements de charges comme on a déjà
pu le voir dans le passé avec le cic il
l'absence de conditionnalité de risque
une fois de plus de ne pas donner de ses
résultats significatifs sur l'emploi
alors comment vous fléché la baisse de
ces impôts de production vers les
entreprises et les régions qui en ont le
plus besoin
merci à monsieur le président pour
répondre aux miss karoutchi de deux
points d'abord sur les observations qui
sont faites pour d'abord dire que je ne
crois pas qu'il s'agisse d'une erreur
d'appréciation du rapporteur général à
l'assemblée au contraire il était
particulièrement moteur pour aboutir sur
ce point là et veiller à cette
compensation
mais au-delà de cette convention qui a
été signée de cet accord qui a été
trouvé vous nous avez aussi interrogé
sur la compensation des recettes aux
collectivités en craignant si j'ai bien
compris qui est d'abord la perte de
recettes et ensuite la compensation en
réalité ils eurent à simultanéité
puisque comme l'indiqué bruno le maire
dans son propos liminaire le psr de
remettre en place d'un bel effet qui
s'appliquera dès le 1er janvier 2021
permettra de compenser la perte de
recettes pour les collectivités
concernées en matière de ses hôtels b b
puisque nous parlons 32000 entreprises
et 86 mille établissements donc il aura
une répartition territoriale permettra
de rembourser
et deuxième de fiscalité perçu en
janvier et donc il y aura si je puis
dire simultanéité de la perte et de la
compensation et il n'y aura pas d'effets
demandé aux collectivités en matière d'
avance de trésorerie
si on reprend ce terme là la deuxième
chose sur la question de la prévision et
de la capacité que nous avons une
maîtrise rationnelle ou non rationnelle
du contexte économique
pour vous dire que nous faisons preuve
de la plus grande prudence nous avons
lorsque nous avons présenté à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
le plfr 3 retenu une hypothèse de
croissance à 1 mons pour son et donc de
déficit à moins 11 points 5 avec une
hypothèse retenue qui était conforme à
la moyenne plutôt basse de l'ensemble
des prévisionnistes
aujourd'hui il y a un certain nombre
d'indicateurs notamment sur les recettes
fiscales sur le niveau de la masse
salariale sur le niveau de la
consommation qui tendent à montrer pour
le moment que la récession pourrait être
moins importante que prévu dans le cadre
de la préparation du plf 21 nous nous
aurons peut-être et même certainement
l'occasion de réviser la trajectoire
macroéconomique et les prévisions qui
sont celles du plfr 3 nous le ferons sur
la base là aussi des indicateurs et des
analystes des analyses qui ne sont
rendus que ce soit par l'insee par la
commission européenne par la banque de
france ou par d'autres organismes qui
procède à ses prévisions et nous faisons
toujours avec une très grande prudence
d'abord parce que nous partageons
l'inquiétude qu'il puisse y avoir un
ruisseau et nous le voyons de l'épidémie
nous partageons aussi le côté qu'à votre
appréciation du côté un peu irrationnel
du comportement des acteurs économiques
en la matière et donc nous y sommes très
attentifs et y compris en terme de
messages au monde économique il n'y a
rien de pire que d'être trop optimiste
et de devoir réviser ensuite dans un
sens négatif des prévisions puisque ça
serait extrêmement à la fois perturbé et
facteurs de perte de confiance sur le
commissariat général au plan vous avez
très certainement pris connaissance de
la lettre de mission du président de la
république qui rappelle que le
commissaire doit éclairer l'ensemble des
choix y compris pour construire une
économie de demain
l articulation avec le plan de relance
et est ainsi je crois assez manifeste
sur les questions posées par le sénateur
à pain je ne reviens pas sur les
questions industrielles ont maté le
transport maritime l'industrie nautique
bruno le maire l'a fait avant moi
simplement sur la question du plan de
relance et l'articulation entre le plan
de relance européen
nous avons évidemment la volonté le
besoin d'aller chercher le retour le
plus important jusqu'à 40 milliards
d'euros et nous aurons l'occasion comme
tous les pays européens de présenter aux
oraux aux autorités européennes à
l'automne entre octobre et novembre
le plan de relance telles que nous vous
l'avons présenté aujourd'hui pour
démontrer que notre plan de relance et
d'une part cohérent avec les priorités
fixées au niveau européen et nous le
savons c'est une forme d'évidence montré
que les dépenses que nous proposons aux
financements européens sont elles aussi
cohérente et répondent aux exigences
attendues des dirigeants européens pour
ensuite obtenir l'autre qu'elles sont
mises en oeuvre le décaissement des
crédits européens
c'est un point qui est important en
termes de mécanique puisque nous devons
mettre en oeuvre le plan pour ensuite
obtenir le décaissement pour ce qui
concerne l'articulation et et j'ajoute
pardonnez moi que le plan européen
prévoit je les dis dans mon ma première
intervention qu'il ait nécessité de
poursuivre les réformes structurelles et
d'envisager les trajectoire
pluriannuelle
je souligne parce que c'est un point qui
est important dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent
en ce qui concerne les plans régionaux
nous y sommes là aussi attentif à chaque
fois que c'est possible nous travaillons
à leur coordination le plus étroite avec
les actions nationales à chaque fois
qu'il est possible de jumeler les
dispositifs pour renforcer leur
efficacité
nous le faisons et l'accord avec les
régions évoqué tout à l'heure prévoit à
la fois un renforcement des cpe air mais
aussi dans le cadre du plan de relance
une délégation de crédit direct de
l'état vers les régions auteur 600
millions d'euros 300 pour la rénovation
thermique des lycées 300 pour les
mobilités douces et dont les choses
s'articule plutôt bien pour répondre à
madame la sénatrice taille brillant
trois choses malheureusement madame 3,3
points de désaccord d'abord sur
l'appréciation que vous avez eu des
propos de bruno le maire concernant la
décroissance je crains vous confondez
les décroissants les écologistes tous
les écologistes ne sont pas des
croissants et pour ce qui nous concerne
nous sommes attachés à une croissance
qui a été évoquée décarbonés de
transition
ne croyons pas la décroissance nous ne
croyons pas à la diminution de la
production à la diminution de la
production de richesses et encore moins
au fait qu'il faille s'éloigner où c'est
que générait de la mise en oeuvre de
nouvelles technologies et donc je pense
que nous pouvons être opposé la
décroissance sans faire quelques procès
que ce soit aux écologistes au contraire
beaucoup trop d'entre eux travaillent
avec nous et je crois partage cette
opposition à la décroissance
deuxième point que vous avez évoqué sur
ce que vous qualifiez d'oubli d'abord
pour pardonnez-moi mais corriger cette
appréciation
le plan prévoit 200 millions d'euros de
soutiens l'hébergement d'urgence
il prévoit et s'il a déjà été mises en
oeuvre
une majoration de l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire ils prévoient 110
millions d'euros d' aides aux
entreprises d'insertion
il prévoit aussi de compléter ce qui a
déjà été fait et lorsque nous mobilisons
31 milliards d'euros avec 28 des gens
engagés pour le chômage partiel
c'est la meilleure façon de protéger
leurs revenus des salariés ocde souligne
que nous sommes le pays avoir le mieux
protéger leurs revenus des salariés
lorsque nous prévoyons 7 milliards
d'euros sur blanc jeunes avec de la
formation avec de l'insertion et au delà
de ce que j'ai dit sur les entreprises
d'insertion au total 1 milliard 300
millions d'euros sur les questions
d'insertion et de formation pour les
reconversions
c'est aussi la preuve que les
préoccupations pour les plus fragiles
lorsque l'on fait en sorte qu'il y ait
des parcours emplois qu'on me pardonne
et mende et des parcours en plein
compétences qu'ils soient sûrs abondé à
hauteur de 80 mille postes c'est aussi
une aide très directe à ceux et à celles
qui sont les plus fragiles
ils vont vraiment il n'ya pas d'oubli
dans ce plan il y a une volonté de
soutenir l'offre de soutenir
l'investissement mais il ya pléthore de
dispositifs en faveur des plus fragiles
de ceux qui perdent leur emploi de ceux
qui sont menacés dans leur venue et je
ne peux pas laisser dire que ce soit
mauvais au contraire pour ceux qui
seront le plus en difficulté et sur les
impôts de production de précisions la
première pour dire que le choix que nous
avons fait guidé par deux objectifs
premiers objectifs l'industrie la
relocalisation et 60% plus de 60% du
bénéfice de la diminution des impôts
vont bénéficier au secteur secondaire
est particulièrement à l'industrie
deuxième objectif les entreprises qui
créent des territoires et qui peuvent
être localisés 42%
des dix milliards d'euros vont profiter
aux deux pays et 30% aux pme ce qui en
soi est je crois une bonne chose pour la
relocalisation et d'industrie du
territoire et pardonnez moi mais je
termine sur un dernier point de
désaccord
vous avez évoqué la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation je vous invite à consulter
l'ensemble des maires qui ont cette
année comme l'année précédente
vu les douzièmes de fiscalité arrivée la
baisse progressive de la taxe
d'habitation acté ou à venir pour le les
vingt derniers pourcents ne s'est jamais
traduit par une attrition des recettes
des collectivités locales et cela était
parfaitement compensé
je termine aussi vite que possible
pardonnez-moi de ses présidents par le
président riquier pour dire que nous
avons prévu effectivement trois
milliards d'euros notamment pour
améliorer les fonds propres mais que
cela vient s'ajouter à des dispositifs
de garanties pour des prêts
participatifs puisque nous voulons
passer du prêt garanti trésorerie à des
prêts participatifs assimilable à des
fonds propres et c'est quelque chose qui
était important nous nous appuierons
notamment sur le secteur bancaire et la
bpi en particulier et pour ce qui
concerne les allègements d'impôts de
production nous sommes dans une logique
évidemment de travail avec l'ensemble
des secteurs professionnels et pour nous
la meilleure réponse meilleur
contrepartie si on doit parler de
contrepartie ce sont les relocalisations
et les créations d'emplois sur le
territoire en ciblant les secteurs que
j'ai évoquées dans la réponse précédente
très bien à chaque élève une dernière
série de questions donc que je vais te
donner successivement la parole à
charles guené christine lagarde philippe
dallier
patrice gélinet et thierry carcenac
charles guené merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
évoqué la la bst à pau de de production
et je crois que c'est une question
légitime lorsque on parle de
compétitivité des entreprises et de
relocalisation
ceci étant on assiste quand même à un
mouvement qui dépasse le plan de relance
puisque après on parlait d' attaques
spéciales
la taxe d'habitation est cette fois la
cvae assez fun tv on on voit très bien
que on est dans un mouvement de
remplacement de la fisk et d'autre les
locales par des impôts nationaux et les
mécanismes que vous évoquez de
dynamiques vont être fortement
je veux dire limité donc ne doit-on pas
considérer que là aussi dans le xème
ministre les élus locaux doivent être
amenés à une révolution mentale ainsi
que les dockers nous le maire et si vous
voulez continuer à rassembler les
français n'est-il pas temps de mettre ce
dossier fait sur le table pour évoquer
une nouvelle gouvernance des finances
locales
alors ça me paraît quelque chose
d'important
deuxième point plus plus technique vous
avez évoqué aussi
les dm théo et il s'agit d' avance qui
seront remboursables mais ceci étant on
a vu lors du dernier cfl que finalement
les dm théo ont été meilleurs que prévu
et peut-être n'aurons nous pas à
utiliser l'ensemble des sommes qui sont
prévues et s'il convenu de les recycler
bien qu'il s'agisse davance et est
toujours le cas échéant à direction des
collectivités locales je pense notamment
la contemporanéité du fctva ou des
choses de ce genre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai bien entendu bruno le
maire qui exposait la difficulté de
consommer rapidement les crédits qui
était proposé et je vais prendre un
exemple précis qui me laisse penser
qu'il aura certainement raison j'ai
regardé un petit peu le secteur
ferroviaire donc le ministre nous a
évoqué un certain nombre d'actions
qu'ils allaient être mises en oeuvre
j'entends bien les travaux de
régénération mais qui dit travaux de
régénération va créer des contraintes
sur le réseau et vous ne savez pas que
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que le
développement du fret ferroviaire
souffre du problème de cadencement et
des problèmes des sillons donc on est là
sur deux actions que vous promouvez mais
qui sont en elles-mêmes contradictoires
ma deuxième question enfin remarque va
porter sur le secteur de la rénovation
énergétique thermique pardon des
bâtiments publics
j'ai vu dans la fiche action que tous
les marchés publics devraient être
lancés avant le 31 décembre 2021 alors
comment allons-nous résoudre les
contraintes architecturales qui se pose
sur un certain nombre de ses bâtiments
est ce à dire que désormais le thermique
passe sur la préservation du patrimoine
j'ai pas d'avis tranché sur la question
c'est une question très fins techniques
pratiques et enfin ma dernière question
portera sur les investissements d'avenir
donc on entend parler de pays à quatre
dans la dans la fiche vous indiquer que
11 milliards de crédits seront consommés
en 2020 et 2021 doublant le montant des
crédits disponibles
effectivement sur l' enveloppe des pays
à troyes il restait globalement autour
de 5 milliards donc est ce à dire qu'en
fait payer à 4 recycle la fin deux pays
à 3 est ce qu'on va avoir deux
programmes qui fonctionnent de manière
concomitante
si oui comment est-ce qu'on va
comprendre l'articulation
sachant que pays à deux étaient toujours
en train de se terminer et est-ce que
sur pays à quatre on aura des vrais
crédit d'impulsion c'est à dire beaucoup
des subventions ou est-ce qu'on va
rester dans la philosophie de pays à
troyes où finalement on avait assez peu
de subventions et beaucoup des avances
remboursables ou des prêts garantis ce
qui n'est pas du tout la même chose en
terme de d'impact pour les entreprises
merci monsieur le président je le dis je
veux vous interroger sur le volet
logement de ce plan de relance aussi
bien l'aspect rénovation thermique des
bâtiments que soutient la construction
qui nous sommes peut-être un peu le
parent pauvre sur la rénovation
thermique
au delà des effectifs en des sommes qui
sont annoncés
tous risquent d'être dans l'exécution
comme le disait bruno le maire et pour
revenir un peu sur ce qui s'est passé
avec l'anah les difficultés qu'elle a pu
connaître pour mettre en oeuvre le
dispositif qui existait alors il ya eu
des problèmes de financement donc là on
peut espérer qu'on en sera sorti
mais il ya aussi eu des problèmes de
traitement des volumes de dossiers et
puis on a eu côté entreprises des
difficultés qui sont apparus un très
clairement on en a encore parlé cet été
avec un effet d'aubaine qui était lié
aux subventions accordées avec le prix
des chaudières qui avait flambé de 1%
on a connu la même problématique avec
l'isolation des bâtiments par
l'extérieur donc au delà des sommes que
vous annoncez qui sont intéressantes
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire qu'est
ce que compte faire le gouvernement pour
qu'effectivement on devienne efficace
sur le terrain dans le coeur du sujet
qui est de sortir des logements qu'ils
soient effectivement convenablement
rénovée du point de vue énergétique
parce que si on ne le fait pas en
parallèle je crains que les résultats ne
soient pas au bout du compte à la
hauteur de nos espérances après sur le
volet soutien à la construction alors
certes il ya ce que la caisse des dépôts
peuvent faire par ailleurs dans son plan
de 26 milliards mais ce que vous comptez
faire de votre côté me semble assez
limité alors j'ai j'ai découvert les 375
millions de soutien au maire densifie
catr alors est ce que vous pourriez
monsieur le ministre me donner une
définition de ce que sera un maire
densifie catr dans le passé on parlait
de maires bâtisseurs
mais bon les sommes qui avaient été mis
sur la table était assez faible et les
critères d'attribution était tellement
serré que fait très peu de communes
concernées ont pu bénéficier des aides
là on nous dit on va aider les mères
densifie catr qu'est-ce que ça peut bien
vouloir dire est ce que 315 millions
vous pensez que c'est à la hauteur à la
hauteur du sujet et enfin je termine là
dessus monsieur le président je voudrais
attirer l'attention du gouvernement
puisqu'on parle à nouveau
d'exonération de cfe pour effectivement
les entreprises industrielles etc
j'aurais attire votre attention du
chemin ministre sur les faits que va
avoir la disparition complète de la taxe
d'habitation le fait qu'il ne reste plus
aux communes que la taxe foncière et le
fait que la totalité des logements
sociaux la totalité du logement
intermédiaire sont exonérés de taxe
foncière pendant 20 à 25 ans ce qui veut
dire que les mères qui construiront
accueilleront de la population et
n'auront aucune rentrées fiscales à côté
pas de taxe d'habitation pas de taxe
foncière est donc au-delà de votre aide
aux mères densifie catr si vous voulez
qu'elle ait un effet quelconque il faut
traiter ce problème de compensation qui
n'est pas assumée par l'état
je sais que ça coûte puisque lors de
l'un des derniers préfèrent vous nous
aviez dit à peu près un milliard si mes
souvenirs sont bons c'est cher monsieur
nuit j'en ai bien conscience
mais puisque nous sommes là pour tout
mettre sur la table et faire en sorte
que le logement également ne soit pas la
victime de cette crise là vous avez un
sujet difficile à traiter
et si vous ne traitez pas au moins
partiellement d'une manière ou d'une
autre vous verrez que les maires ne
consommons pas beaucoup de votre 75
millions je le prends
le président du ministre mes chers
collègues une observation préalable je
pense que dans la présentation du plan
de relance
il rit intérêt à faire preuve d'un peu
plus de rigueur c'est à dire puisqu'on
d' amalgame des choses qui sont à la
fois de nature différente ou qui sont
dans des tempos un peu différent tout
d'abord on a des dépenses aux dépenses
réelles on a des dépenses aux dépenses
de vagues des actions de trésorerie qui
n'ont pas le même le même impact
il ya également la question de
l'étalement dans le temps et la prise en
compte de décisions qui ont déjà été
prises donc si on veut réhabiliter la
parole publique la parole politique il
faut effectivement qu'on fasse qu'on est
con et cette exigence de rigueur
deuxième élément effectivement d'autres
l'ont dit avant moi on attend les
mesures aussi concrets sur un certain
nombre de dispositifs qu'on aura dans le
cadre du plf et du plfss pour pouvoir se
prononcer je vais revenir sur ce qui a
été dit avant moi sur le fait qu' on a
des des actions des décisions des
perspectives qui portent plus sur les
entreprises que sur les ménages c'est
une réalité
s'agissant des entreprises on peut là
aussi d'une certaine manière critique et
les le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
conditionnalité la fois sur le plan
environnemental et sur le plan social
c'est dommageable puisque les risques on
est évoquée d'ailleurs le par le
ministre le maire
il ya des risques qu'il y ait des
stratégies d'opportunité de la part d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises et cette
conditionnalité aurait été participer
sur les mesures qui auraient vite et ce
genre d'attitude s'agissant des ménages
devrait revenir sur ce que ce qui a été
dit à la voix par ma collègue et les
réponses que vous avez bien voulu
apporter
on a aujourd'hui des situations de
grande précarité
d'ores et déjà l'insee vient de publier
une étude hier sur l'offre
l'accroissement du taux de pauvreté en
france entre 2017 et 2018
et au fait que les ménages les plus
riches ont bénéficié d'un croissant de
revenus en particulier des revenus du
patrimoine lié notamment aux revenus
et aux placements financiers et qu'en
contrepartie effectivement les d'autres
ménages ont subi les conséquences de la
suppression des munitions des apl et
d'un certain nombre de réformes sur des
allocations sociales on est dans un
contexte d'aujourd'hui où
malheureusement le risque de voir ce
taux de pauvreté s'accroître est une
réalité et donc la nécessité de faire un
effort particulier aux d'initiation ces
ménages à la fois du point de vue humain
et social mais également du point de vue
de l'accompagnement de la relance
économique parce qu'on est certain que
les moyens accordés à ces ménages seront
nécessairement immédiatement générons
immédiatement de la compensation
peut-être souligné deux ou trois choses
plus particulièrement sa a été évoquée
aussi sur la question de la culture
aujourd'hui nous avons secteur culturel
en grande difficulté de rêver le mensuel
également de la restauration c'est
évoquer souligner également la situation
particulière connaît l'agriculture
aujourd'hui qui est soumis aux aléas
climatiques que vous connaissez mais pas
seulement et qu'il est nécessaire
d'avoir un accompagnement fort à la fois
pour aider à l'adaptation à la
transition de cette activité d
exploitation mais également pour aider à
la réorganisation des filières c est
fondamental
il ya des enjeux et c'est à dire au mois
deux à la fois de qualité de
l'alimentation mais également de soins
de thé national
s'agissant du numérique devrait
souligner aussi que l'on a une forte
opportunité à travers cette technologie
pour travailler est vrai un
réaménagement du territoire au regard de
ce que sont les à la fois les attentes
des français mais également les attentes
des entreprises qui ont compris tout
l'intérêt qu'elle pouvait avoir à
disposer de deux salariés situés en
france et installés dans des lieux où le
les mètres carrés de foncier ne sont pas
ce qu'elles peuvent trouver dans des
zones beaucoup plus dense donc devrait
véritablement insisté sur la nécessité
de poursuivre et de développer les
moyens qui ont été engagés pour cette ce
développement de ses infrastructures
sachant que du point de vue des
mentalités je crois que là il ya un
frein ou des freins qui on est et on
sautait au cours de ces derniers mois on
s'est aperçu qu'en télétravail on
pouvait faire
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et que ce
n'était plus à un problème pour
l'efficacité du fonctionnement des
entreprises
deux autres points les gens je resterai
là j'aimerais savoir très précisément ça
a été évoqué par le ministre le maire
comment les communes les plus petites
vont pouvoir bénéficier de
l'accompagnement en matière de
rénovation thermique de leurs bâtiments
publics la décide effectivement a été vu
sur les écrits du augmenté néanmoins la
dessine ne n'est pas nécessairement une
dotation pour les communes les plus
petites jeu pratiqué aux communes
rurales et puis vous pourriez vous re
préciser les modalités de compensation
de la perte des pertes de recettes
fiscales domaniale quelques 7 évoqué
aujourd'hui on a encore des incertitudes
chez nos collègues élus locaux qui
aujourd'hui n'a pas exactement quel va
être les quelles vont être les modalités
de calcul de ces pertes de recettes et
je voudrais simplement terminer
simplement pour assister ce qui sur ce
qui a pu être dit précédemment
aujourd'hui le lien entre le
contribuable et les collectivités
locales devient de plus en plus ténu il
ya une urgence à réformer la fiscalité
mais d'une manière plus générale à
réformer les finances locales c'est
également le volet dotation pour
permettre le maintien de l'autonomie
locale et le lien entre le contribuable
et et les collectivités et les élus et
les électeurs c'est la base de la
démocratie et retravaillé également à la
péréquation des dotations jo merci
hawley thierry carcenac merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
beaucoup d'éléments ont été évoqués je
voudrais revenir sur sur deux points le
ministre tout à l'heure nous a parlé des
problèmes à venir et notamment des plans
sociaux et il a évoqué la possibilité de
plans sociaux domaine
la question que je voudrais vous poser
concerne les grands groupes
lorsque vous êtes sur les territoires
vous avez des établissements et vous
avez les conséquences établissement par
établissement et vous n'avez aucune
visibilité sur ce qui se passe au niveau
du grand groupe et le ministre a évoqué
le sens des responsabilités je pense que
parfois il faudrait aller plus loin chez
en cas bien précis en tête
il s'agit d'un grand groupe verallia
dont vous avez des fonds de pension très
important à l'intérieur qui essaient de
se retirer parfois vous avez la
participation de la bpia l'intérieur et
il s'agit d'un secteur puisqu'il s'agit
du verre ou la transition écologique le
verre est important et dans mon
département j'ai la verrerie ouvrière
d'albi qui sapent leur verrerie ouvrière
n'est plus une coopérative
mais dans ce grand groupe et nous
n'avons aucune visibilité sur le plan
social qui est en train d'être mises en
place et donc ma question concerne les
grands groupes
comment en matière de territorialisation
pourrait-on avoir une approche j'ai
rencontré la préfète dessus nous n'avons
aucun élément
comment pouvez-vous haut niveau de
l'état
informée de façon plus importante
les les parlementaires sur le territoire
ça c'est le premier point le second
point concerne une des missions que j'ai
ici dans cette commission des finances
et l'immobilier de l'état
on a parlé du plan de relance et de
l'action owni près des entreprises
auprès des collectivités locales comment
l'état ont-ils accélérer ses actions en
matière d'immobilier de l'état notamment
sur une cité administrative
où nous avons constaté qu on pourrait
peut-être aller un peu plus vite et est
ce que dans le budget de 2021
on pourra aller plus loin sur les
rénovations en la matière je vous
remercie
merci mais c'est le président dernière
série de questions et donc d'abord mots
pour remercier tous les participants et
les intervenants pour la qualité des
interventions et cet échange ce matin
avant de venir aux questions posées par
charles guené c'est la question posée
par charles guené sur le financement des
collectivités locales de manière
générale est une question qui vous le
savez me passionne elle était reprise
par d'autres de vos collègues
nous pourrions rester je crois et blanc
et l'autre et les uns et les autres
extrêmement longtemps sur ce sujet là et
notamment sur ses rapports entre
l'autonomie financière et l'autonomie
fiscale et la lecture qu'on fait le
conseil constitutionnel et la lecture
que l'on pourrait en faire dans le cadre
d'une révision
mais pour rester sur les deux points
précis que vous avez évoqué sur l'action
ddmt haut nous avons provisionné et
c'est l'occasion pour moi de dire que le
plfr travail a porté sur des provisions
en matière de compensation 2 milliards 7
qui correspondait à ce que nous
envisagions à ce moment-là de diminution
ddmt au perçue par les départements
aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez noté mais
les rentrées fiscales de dmt eaux sont
plus importantes que prévu en tout cas
moins mauvaise qu'attendu mais nous
craignons et c'est là un point de
prudence qu'il a un effet de retard
entre la date de réalisation des
affaires générant de ddmt au leur date
d'enregistrement et ainsi l'encaissement
par l'état si nous avions la certitude
que l'intégralité de la période de creux
qui se traduisent par le fait que
quasiment aucune transaction était
conclue était totalement absorbée est
déjà derrière nous en matière
d'enregistrement
nous pourrions faire preuve d'optimisme
est envisagé tel ou tel mécanisme
ça n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et donc
nous sommes extrêmement prudents sur la
réalité des recettes sur les derniers
mois voir les premiers mois de l'année
2021 avec cet effet retard sur la
question du soutien à l'investissement
et je fais le lien avec la question
posée par le sénateur joly sur la ds il
est
votre suggestion de la tva j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire pendant les débats
sur le plfr 3 nous n'avons pas retenu la
modalité de d'anticipation des
remboursements de fctva
contrairement à ce qui avait été fait en
2009 car nous avons considéré que
c'était un fusil un coup dans la mesure
où beaucoup de collectivités sont déjà
rien de plus sain et qu'en 2020 les
sections d'investissement sont
particulièrement bien financé du côté
des excédents de fonctionnement qui
était en hausse permanente depuis trois
ans et particulièrement en 2019 et du
fait aussi que l'annuité de fctva versés
en 2020 est particulièrement importante
est que nous sommes plus sur une
difficulté de financement résiduelles ou
au cas par cas de tel ou tel projet est
de mise en oeuvre
nous avons inscrit 1 milliards d'euros
de dsl et je rappelle que nous avons
donné des outils de souplesse pour son
utilisation souplesse dans le fait que
contrairement aux autres années
cette fraction des s'il pourra faire
l'objet de reports dès lors que les
engagements oraux des prix que les
premiers ordres de service auront été
passés souplesse aussi par le fait que
nous avons cela a été dit par bruno le
maire autoriser les préfets à utiliser
cette tranche supplémentaire pour
abonder des financements déjà acté au
type de la dsi de la detr sur tel ou tel
projet lorsque le financement accordées
initialement n'était pas suffisant pour
avoir un effet levier et permettre le
démarrage du chantier souplesse enfin
puisque nous avons aussi autoriser les
préfets à réattribuer des dotations des
notaires ou des cils déjà accordé en
début d'année 2020 en cas d'évolution du
projet notamment si le nouveau projet a
pour vocation de répondre à la crise
sanitaire
j'apporte une précision qui est
importante et qui fait écho à ce que
disait le sénateur joly nous avons
adressé des jacqueline gourault plus
particulièrement une circulaire aux
préfets et indiqués comme vous nous
l'avez demandé dans le débat
parlementaire que sur cette tranche
exceptionnelle d'un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires les critères
d'attribution
répondez à la fois aux critères
d'habitude d'attribution traditionnel de
la ds il mais aussi aux critères
d'attribution de la detr ce qui signifie
que les préfets peuvent mobiliser cette
tranche supplémentaire de des cils pour
des projets habituellement financé par
delà des notaires et je précise enfin
que chaque préfet a reçu la circulaire
et surtout s'est vu notifier ce qui
représente département par département
en termes de crédits nouveaux cette dsi
supplémentaires
sur la question de madame labarthe
concernant le ferroviaire le choix que
nous faisons en lien avec la direction
générale du groupe bien évidemment et
d'aller et de cibler nos efforts à la
fois sur le rattrapage des pertes liées
aux coville sur le soutien au fret
ferroviaire et sur la régénération des
lignes considérant que la sncf paye
encore aujourd'hui dans son intégralité
une course aux nouveaux équipements qui
s'était traduite par un désengagement
des opérations de maintenance une
dégradation du réseau et une diminution
des performances ce que vous dites est
juste en termes d'effet lorsqu'on on
réalise des travaux d'entretien
malheureusement nous sommes aussi
obligés de nous inscrire sur un temps
long et nous considérons que c'est là la
meilleure façon d'aider la sncf
non seulement à traverser la crise mais
aussi à préparer son avenir avec cet
ordre de priorité sur la rénovation
énergétique et ça fait le lien avec eux
une question posée par thierry carcenac
se confirme comme à l'occasion de la
conférence nationale de l'immobilier
public que j'ai présidé ce lundi à
clermont-ferrand
nous avons ouvert l'appel d'offres pour
quatre milliards d'euros
deux appels d'offres enfin qui concerne
les bâtiments d'état au sens propre du
terme
et un qui concerne les bâtiments
universitaires sont aussi des bâtiments
d'état mais avec des caractéristiques
particulières
notre objectif est l'accélération et
dans la mesure où les opérateurs ont un
mois pour déposer les projets et
qu'ensuite nous nous donnons six
semaines pour les instruire
il est évident que notre but est avant
tout de financer des projets qui étaient
pas qu'ils sont prêts pour certains qui
ont fait l'objet d'une labellisation par
l'équipe mais qui n'avait pas obtenu de
financement et donc cela répond aux
objections ou crainte madame lagarde en
matière d'archivés de préconisations
architectural puisque nous sommes sur
des choses déjà prêt nous voulons aller
très vite et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons tous les
marchés publics soit notifiée avant le
31 décembre 2021
puisque nous savons aussi qu'une fois le
marché notifié l'entreprise peut dans le
cadre de son financement habituel faire
valoir cette notification pour se
garantir un certain nombre de
financements à court et à moyen terme
donc c'est la démarche que nous avons
retenue et cela vient s'ajouter au
programme 348 de rénovation du site
administratif doté d'un milliards sur le
quinquennat programme qui fait l'objet
de mises en oeuvre je suis désolé de
prendre cet exemple très particulier
mais
lundi lors de la cnil que je présidais à
clermont nous avons à la fois annoncé qu
indépendamment de l'appel à projets nous
retenions par avance de projets de sites
administratifs de l'état à clermont
ferrand
parce que ça vient en réalité compléter
une décision de juillet qui nous avait
permis d'intégrer la cité administrative
de l'état clairement dans le programme
348 ce qui permettra de rénover les
trois logements principaux de trois
bâtiments principaux de l'état sur
clermont ferrand dans les deux ans dans
les deux ans qui viennent
mais tout ce qui peut être accéléré en
la matière pour la mise en oeuvre de 348
nous en sommes évidemment preneur vous
savez qu'on n'est pas sur un problème de
disponibilité de crédit mais plus c'est
un problème de mise en oeuvre des
programmes qui ont été retenus sur le
pays à quatre
vous avez évoqué cela madame la varde il
s'agit de crédits nouveaux
il s'agit de crédits nouveaux et
j'apporte une précision pardonnez moi un
métier très technique pour dire qu'il
s'agit de 20 milliards d'euros de
crédits nouveaux 9 au titre du budget
général
dans le cas du pays à pays à 4 et 11 au
titre du plan de relance et que la seule
nuance que je pourrai apporter mais il
s'agit toujours créé de nouveau c'est
que ces 20 milliards 1 taye la
prolongation de la rémunération des
dotations non consommables des pays à 1
et 2 mais sous forme de financements
nouveaux donc il n'ya pas de recyclage
contraire c'est vraiment un coup de
booster sur la question du logement et
les inquiétudes de philippe dallier sur
la mise en oeuvre du programme et les
questions de formation
nous avons actuellement des contacts et
c'est principalement le mts sous l'égide
de d'elisabeth bornes et d'emmanuel voir
bon qui les mène avec les fédérations du
bâtiment sur la question la qualité des
travaux
la mobilisation des crédits de formation
pour la montée en puissance nous avons
aussi des réflexions sur les questions
de labellisation qui accompagne parfois
d'obligations de labellisation celle
telle ou telle entreprise ne peut pas
intervenir
à défaut d'avoir tel ou tel label nous
essayons d'élargir le spectre tout en
garantissant la qualité des travaux
réalisés ça n'est pas une mince affaire
mais c'est aussi une des conditions de
la rapidité de mise en oeuvre et du fait
que cela bénéficie à les entreprises
implantées sur les territoires sur les
questions de
de soutien la construction et notamment
le dispositif des mers densifie catr je
veux vous rassurer sur le fait que les
crédits sont consommés puisqu'en réalité
nous avons là aussi des premiers
échanges avec les associations d'élus
mené par l'uimm c'était pour déterminer
ce qu'est la mer densifie catr et
notamment comment mesurer de la
construction du dépôt de permis de
construire sur des parcelles déjà
existant déjà urbanisées sans
artificialisation des sols ce qui est
assez conforme à la logique que nous
poursuivons est dès lors qu'une commune
sera intégrée dans les zones qui seront
certainement défini et respectera ses
critères
elle sera versée automatiquement sans
qu'il y ait lieu de la demande et ou de
faire valoir un dépôt une candidature au
titre de maire densifie catr et donc
c'est vraiment la volonté d'accompagner
et de le faire en deux fois sur les
exercices 2021 et 2022
très certainement au cours de l'été pour
avoir un temps suffisamment long
d'examen des permis déposé des projets
menés par la commune mais le détail de
la mise en oeuvre est encore en cours de
discussion entre le rct et les
associations d'élus sur les questions
d'exonération vous ouvrez un débat que
nous avons à l'occasion de chaque élève
et je confirme que ce que vous appelez
le milliard existe il s'agit en réalité
de l'écart qui s'est progressivement
creusé entre les recettes dont devraient
bénéficier les collectivités la
composante de la compensation qu'apporte
l'état jeudi progressivement puisque
vous connaissez comme moi les les
mécanismes d'écrêtement ou autres gels
de compensation sur les questions posées
par monsieur joly donc j'ai répondu sur
la d2 terre et la ds il je souligne
monsieur le sénateur que nous ne
cherchons pas à dire autre chose que ce
qui existe dans plan de relance j'ai moi
même dans mon propos liminaire rappelé
que certains crédits déportés par le
préfet c'est ce que d'autres avaient
adopté dans le plfr et nous aurons
l'occasion dans le débat parlementaire
d'une véritable cartographie de la
manière dont était construit le plan de
relance sans qu'il y ait aucune
difficulté à cela sur la question des
ménages je vous renvoie à ce que j'ai
répondu à votre collègue pour aller plus
avant j'ajoute simplement il faut aussi
garder en tête au moins permis pour
mémoire ce qui a été fait précédemment
en matière de revalorisation
d'un grand nombre de minima sociaux ou
d'augmentation de la plume d'activité
bruno le maire l'a dit tout petits
billets que je veux souligner mais sans
ouvrir nécessairement le débat à ce
stade le plf nous permettra l'étude 2018
que vous avez évoquées ne pointe que
l'évolution des revenus au sens strict
du terme ça jamais sans jamais prendre
en compte les compensations par exemple
sur la question des appels
l'étude a retenu la baisse de 5 euros
n'a pas retenu la baisse de loyer qui
avait été une des contreparties aux
types de la rls donc ça independent
méthode mais on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir sur la culture il y à deux
milliards d'euros qui sont prévus dans
le cadre du plan de relance vous l'avez
vu et la ministre et est en discussions
avec les acteurs du secteur sur
l'agriculture
je vais souligné que le plan que nous
vous proposons s'élève à 1 milliard 200
millions d'euros ce qui a été dit par
bruno le maire orpea
c'est important a souligné et ça
s'ajoute aux 3 milliards d'euros que le
plr porte traditionnellement en matière
de politique agricole
lorsqu'on part de 3 milliards d'euros
annuels que l'on ajoute un milliard deux
sur deux en plus les éléments du pays a
je pense que c'est un développement des
moyens consacrés à l'agriculture qu'on
avait rarement voire jamais connu
dernier point vous avez évoqué le
mécanisme de garantie pour les communes
nous avons voulu un mécanisme qui soit
aussi simple que possible
nous savons calculer la moyenne des
recettes fiscales et de manuels et par
domaniale je renvoie l'instruction
comptable qui détermine la liste des
recettes domaniales de chacune des
collectivités communes interco sur la
moyenne 2017 2019 nos agents de la dgfip
vont faire une estimation en fonction de
ce que nous connaissons à date de des
mêmes recettes tout cas d un périmètre
constant des mêmes recettes perçues en
2020 par les communes et nous verserons
un acompte
nous avons donné comme consigne que
l'acompte soit à la fois suffisamment
élevé pour aider la commune et qu'il
soit aussi calculé au plus juste pour
éviter que des phénomènes de trop perçu
des demandes de remboursement l'année
prochaine les débuts 2021
lorsque nous connaîtrons exactement le
vrai volume en fin de volume constatées
de recettes fiscales domaniale de la
collectivité
nous compléterons l'acompte au
malheureusement ça peut arriver
nous demanderons une régularisation dans
le sens inverse
la date n'est pas tout à fait fixe
pardon la conte
nos services sont en train de calculer
les estimations et nous espérons que cet
acompte puisse intervenir courant
novembre
donc avant évidemment la fin de
l'exercice et essayer de la raison pour
laquelle nous allons évoquer dans le
plfr 3 unis des provisions puisque
évidemment si la situation fiscale
s'avère moins dégradés que prévu pour
les collectivités il n'y aura pas lieu
d'aller aussi loin que ce qui est prévu
dans le plf r3 al'inverse s'il était
plus dégradés duras lieu d'aller plus
loin et nous y ferons évidemment face et
ce sont nos services qui vont calculer
cet acompte par la démarche auprès des
collectivités sans que les communes et
les intercommunalités ou à faire
quelques calculs que ce soit enfin je
finis par monsieur le sénateur carcenac
vous avez évoqué le cas de l'entreprise
verallia permettez moi si vous le voulez
bien sûr le sénateur de répondre d'une
part en disant que le ministère
l'économie des finances de manière
générale entretient un lien avec les
grands groupes et cherchent à
accompagner les élus pour y voir plus
clair pardonner pardon pour l'expression
que nous mobilisons régulièrement sous
l'autorité de bruno le maire le comité
interministériel de restructuration
industrielle
là aussi pour avoir un outil de pilotage
et et de discussions sur pour ce qui
concerne verallia en particulier que
vous avez évoquées si vous le voulez
bien et peut-être pour ne pas faire
durer plus longtemps la séance monsieur
le président j'ai quelques éléments là
que nous pouvons partager l'un et
l'autre je pense qu'il vous concernent
plus directement que l'ensemble des
commissaires encore présents parfait
donc s'il n'y a plus de question schleck
je vais remercier les niches pour la
précision des réponses apportées et je
vais laisser lever la séance sur ces
auditions concernant le plan de relance
voilà pour cette audition de bruno le
maire et d'olivier dussopt pts les
ministres étaient entendus à la suite de
la présentation du plan de relance du
gouvernement la semaine dernière
on enchaîne tout de suite avec une
audition toujours lié à l'épidémie de
couronnes à virus la commission d'
enquête sur la gestion de la pandémie
poursuit ses travaux aujourd'hui c'est
la politique de dépistage qui intéresse
les sénateurs regarder si donc audition
consacrée à la politique de dépistage
aujourd'hui merci à nos intervenants
d'être présent je présente les excuses
du président milan président de la
commission des affaires sociales et
président de cette commission denquête
qui est retenu sur son département
donc ce matin nous avons en audition le
docteur françois blanchecotte président
du syndicat des biologistes médicaux
professeur bruno lina virologue
laboratoire de virologie des hospices
civils de lyon et membre du conseil
scientifique et le professeur philippe
froguel endocrinologue généticien
directeur de l'umr inserm 1283 et
directeur de l'institut européen de
génomique du diabète l'égide voilà avec
la question des masques nous assistons
avec les tests au deuxième grand fiasco
de cette crise j'espère que notre
audition de ce matin permettra de
déterminer les raisons pour lesquelles
notre pays s'est trouvé se trouvent
encore dans l'incapacité de répondre à
l'injonction de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
tester tester tester alors que d'autres
pays ils sont parvenus alors que le
génome du virus a été connu très tôt
dans la crise la mise en place de
procédures et le développement de
capacités n'ont visiblement pas
correctement suivi la doctrine semble
avoir été très changeante les
organisations inadaptés les capacités
insuffisantes la fiabilité discutable et
les délais ans
tout état de cause beaucoup trop lent
pour que les thèses plus de jouer leur
rôle dans la lutte contre l'épidémie
cette question des délais est cruciale
on peut sérieusement s'interroger sur
l'intérêt de réaliser un million de
tests par semaine si un prélèvement ne
peut intervenir que plusieurs jours
après des symptômes et si l'obtention du
résultat intervient encore plusieurs
jours après constatant l'embolie du
système le gouvernement envisage
désormais des restrictions d'accès à
rebours de ses choix initiaux
cette situation appelle des correctifs
urgent et nous souhaiterions savoir
quels sont les préconisations de nous
inviter à ce sujet je demanderai donc
d'intervenir en préambule à chacun
d'entre vous pour vous positionner
placer votre message pour cinq minutes
chacun puisque vous aurez après le temps
de passer au détail en répondant aux
questions de nos rapporteur plus aux
questions de nos commissaires voilà la
procédure bien entendu chacun et précis
dans ses questions et bien entendu dans
ses réponses et nous devons garder le
masque tout au long de cette audition
merci pour votre vigilance
et comme c'est une commission denquête
je vous rappelle que tout propos
mensongers et sanctionné d'une amende
pouvant aller jusqu'à 75 mille euros et
même d'une peine de prison pouvant aller
jusque 5 ans et je vais vous demander de
prêter serment donc alors docteur
françois blanchecotte prêté serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité rien que
la vérité vous levé la main droite et
vous dites je le jure très bien profond
bruno lina prêté serment dire la vérité
toute la vérité levé la main droite et
dit je le jure je jure professeur
philippe faut qu'elle prêté serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité de lever
la main droite et de dire je le jure
merci ceci étant fait et bien ma foi je
vais passer la parole dans l'ordre de
nos intervenants si vous en êtes
d'accord donc françois blanchecotte
c'est à vous et vous allumez votre micro
pour ça bien merci beaucoup messieurs
mesdames de nous recevoir d'abord pour
cette commission denquête et de pouvoir
s'exprimer devant vous en ce qui
concerne cette crise pour ce qui
concerne le secteur libéral privée
puisque je ne représente que celui ci un
mot au départ c'est qu'effectivement
nous n'étions pas prêts nous n'étions
pas prêts à faire techniquement et
massivement ces tests ç'a donné
plusieurs
plusieurs finalement période qui se sont
passés à la fois que les tests ont été
extrêmement au départ centralisé sur les
hôpitaux qui devait les faire ensuite on
s'est adressé au privé dans ce phénomène
comme vous l'avez très bien rappelé nous
n'avons été pas dans le viseur de la
santé publique puisque les biologistes
médicaux ne sont pas dans le code de
santé publique ne sont que les
pharmaciens les médecins et donc nous
avons au départ eu aucun masque aucun
équipement
d'autre part nous sommes dans une
démarche française d'accréditation qui
est une norme mondiale dans lequel nous
avons effectivement que 120 plateau
technique en france qui sont accrédités
par le cofrac
sur les 900 labo plateau par dont 900
plateau technique français est privé
donc c'était une contrainte parce que
certaines ars au départ on refuse
évidemment que des laboratoires
développent ces technologies
même s'ils avaient déposé des dossiers
en amont mais étant donné qu'ils
n'avaient pas été vérifiés
ils n'ont pas eu l'autorisation de le
faire ensuite nous avons eu de problèmes
de l'an un tuyau d'étranglement pour
dire ça comme ça pour les réactifs et
les commandes de machines très dès le
départ nous sommes soumis nous les
laboratoires privés à une autorisation
d'achat qui est lié évidemment bien sûr
au remboursement de ces tests nous avons
une commission dirar cheese ation des
actes une achab dans lequel décide au
travers de la has quels sont les
réactifs que nous pouvons utiliser
nous sommes arrivés au journal officiel
le 8 mars
dans cette commission et nous avions une
liste qui a été établie de six
fournisseurs seulement cette liste au
cours du mois de mars a évolué vers 14
18 puis 34 et ses fournisseurs
imaginez un marché mondial messieurs
mesdames dans lequel vous achetez avec
des fournisseurs que vous ne connaissez
pas parce que c'est les fournisseurs
asiatiques avec lequel nous travaillons
pas d'habitude et dans lequel nous avons
une liste limitative de réactifs
autorisée sur le sol français
ça ce sont les conditions que nous avons
vécu dès le départ et qui ont été
extrêmement compliqué pour me faire vite
nous avons essayé de d'ajuster en tout
cas nos commandes d'ajuster avec tous
les déboires que nous avons eus je
regrette au passage que la décision du
confondues lors du confinement à la fin
du confinement n'est pas eu de port de
masque obligatoire
nous avons mis très longtemps à ce que
nos personnels puissent être considérés
comme des gens qu'on peut protéger
au départ ce sont les labos privés qui
s'en sont chargés aussi bien aux
secrétaires médicales que nos
techniciens de laboratoire nous avons
acheté nous mêmes tout ce qui concerne
les protections de nos accueils de
laboratoire et nous avons pris la sage
décision de fermer une grand nombre de
laboratoires au départ de mettre un
certain nombre de techniciens en chômage
partiel de façon à protéger des équipes
ce qui est encore le cas aujourd'hui
puisque nous avons compensé
financièrement les 16% nous avons payé
les gens en arrêt de travail et
aujourd'hui nous sommes à une situation
où si ce chiffre 2 millions est
absolument un chiffre qu'il faut arriver
à faire c'est ce qui a été fait a priori
la semaine dernière c'est pas pour moi
un objectif ce qui manque c'est les
cibles donc aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
une loge ments à la fois des prises en
charge des patients et un allongement
des prises en charge technique
c'est vrai que les délais se sont
allongés méo faut comprendre aussi que
les fournisseurs mondiaux ont des quotas
par pays
quand vous donnez de vous acheter des
machines il ya des quotas qui sont
distribués et donc quand vous doubler la
quantité à faire très rapidement
eh bien vous trouvez sur le marché
mondial à voir est en file indienne pour
acheter des produits des réactifs et où
aujourd'hui nos commandes dans le privé
s'allonge
elles sont de trois à quatre semaines et
comme je le dis souvent avec amusement
quand on achète un appareil et bien
c'est pas une machine à café on le
branche pas et ça marche pas tout de
suite il faut le valider
certifié cette machine le connecter et
souvent ça demande une bonne semaine
avant qu'on puisse être opérationnel je
salue le gouvernement qui a financé
entièrement cidep avec les ingénieurs le
privé nous avons connecté en quatre
semaines l'ensemble des labos privés
et si aujourd'hui il n'y avait pas ce
système là nous n'aurions aucun résultat
en ligne correctement effectuée pour la
population maintenant je pense qu'on est
haut dans une vague absolument de creux
parce que on n'a pas aujourd'hui encore
suffisamment de matériel pour répondre à
la demande mais on a surtout des publics
incessants qui viennent nous voir pour
vous citer un exemple je viens de
recevoir ce matin sur mon téléphone
qu'on a les dépister tous les admr de
l'indre et loire
je sais pas comment on va faire l'état
des mers le médico social
tous les gens qui interviennent voilà
pour les parisiens voilà et donc je sais
même pas comment on va faire j'ai pas de
solution technique du tout pour faire ça
représente des milliers de personnes
donc la préfète avait évoqué la semaine
dernière qu'on ne compte des pistes les
35 millions 35 mille étudiants de tours
voilà c'est ce genre de décision
aujourd'hui qui nous noie complètement
donc j'ai fait un appel très claires
j'ai fait une déclaration il ya quelques
jours en disant il faut qu'on soit clair
en ce moment qu'est ce qu'on veut est-ce
qu'on veut prendre en jambes et en
charge les gens et dans ce cas là il
faut créer une ville d'hyères absolument
par les médecins symptomatologie qu les
cas contacts et que c'est free hier soit
prioritairement prise dans les
laboratoires et qu'on s'engage sur ce
fameux délai de prise en charge de
rendez vous et de dans les deux d'eads
et résultat est qu'on peut avoir des
centres ad-hoc peut-être extérieur
peut-être avec les dettes de tous nos
mères pour créer des centres dans lequel
on accueille le plus grand nombre de
champs pour voir comment on peut faire
mais qu'on n'est pas ces contraintes de
délais que les gens soient effectivement
comment dire rassuré sur le fait qu'ils
vont avoir le test mais qu'il y aura
plus de délais que les délais
s'allongent parce qu'aujourd'hui je vous
annonce très clairement que les
violences se multiplient aux accueils
des laboratoires que ça devient
insupportable nos secrétaires ont des
insultes tous les jours parce qu'il ya
eu le problème des vols etc dans les
vols nos compagnies aériennes ont
demandé 48 ou 72 heures
il ya des gens qui sont au guichet
d'embarquement à orly ou ailleurs et
dans les autres villes de france et qui
attendent pour en voler que d'avoir le
résultat de thé spécial donc ça devient
insoutenable
on ne peut pas y arriver et le deuxième
problème que nous avons c'est
l'éducation nationale puisque
aujourd'hui dès qu'un parent professeur
un enfant a évidemment détecter qu'il
était revenu mais peut être positif
toute la classe doit être testé on n'y
arrivera pas c'est pas possible
donc il faut que j'ai fait appel à la
société française de pédiatrie pour
qu'elle se prononce pour savoir s'il y
avait un âge qu'est ce qu'on faisait
exactement
mais si les écoles ferment parce que
tous les enfants sont pas testés ou vous
pouvez pas ramener votre enfant parce
qu'il apparente spcr je vous prie de
croire que là je sais même pas comment
on va faire
c'est plus un problème de préleveurs on
a ouvert les vannes aux préleveurs on a
à peu près plus de 350 mille quatre cent
mille préleveur en france potentiel
c'est plus à la question c'est un moment
donné reste qu'on se recentre sur la
maladie comment dépister les gens
comment évoluer les classeurs il faut
que la cellule de cas contacts se mette
bien en place et dévalue les gens autour
d'eux on sait maintenant mais c'est pas
moi qu'il expliquerait selon nos
collègues scientifiques évidemment qui
pourra en parler le mieux
comment se dissémine le virus est
finalement qu on a commandé ccc centre
épidémique mais il faut qu'on revienne à
notre métier initial faut qu'on puisse
répondre évidemment à chaque français
chaque française qui a un doute mais
aujourd'hui un français sur quatre qui
vient se faire dépister dans la file
d'attenté c'est juste pour se rassurer
pour imaginer qu'il ya quand même des
français qui viennent plusieurs fois par
semaine donc il ya toutes sortes de
choses chacun une bonne raison de venir
dans cette file attentes et donc c'est
très important que vous compreniez que
les files d'attentes devant les
laboratoires c'est pas pour prendre part
les gens mais y aller même à la poste si
elles mêmes dans les grands centres où
on rentre pas des milliers de gens en
même temps dans un local
ça c'est une précaution simplement de
respecter les règles de distanciation
d'hygiène et tout mais il ya aussi ce
souci de revenir sur l'essentiel c'est à
dire l'essentiel refaire venir les
médecins au centre du jeu et ensuite
qu'on puisse faire correctement notre
métier
après le prélèvement salivaire a priori
mais peut-être que le professeur bruno
lina l'exprimera mieux que moi et
peut-être une potez envisagée mais qui
simplifiera simplement le prélèvement et
après quand aux tests antigénique
qu'a proposé le ministre pour l'instant
moi j'ai pas de résultats scientifiques
pour me prononcer sur ce domaine là donc
en tout cas les biologistes ont motivé
je peux vous dire que ils sont
aujourd'hui et tout ce qui me remonte de
la france entière
c'est qu'ils sont à genoux clairement
qu' on a promis des choses où s'étaient
engagés vis-à-vis des français est
qu'aujourd'hui maintenant évidemment on
est beaucoup de français attendent et
rouspète parce qu'ils ont parlé résultat
au bout de cinq jours et donc il faut
revenir à l'essentiel et c'est peut-être
l'objet de cette commission de rappeler
ce qu'est l'essentiel dans ce pays pour
qu'on puisse traiter cette épidémie
toujours merci monsieur prix merci merci
monsieur ben je veux être professeur
lina oui merci monsieur le président
donc je voudrais juste un élément
clarification moi je viens ici en tant
que virologues responsable du centre
national de référence pour les virus
respiratoires donc on a été un petit peu
au centre du développement et de la mise
en oeuvre d'un certain nombre d'outils
puis après du déploiement etc
par contre je sais que vous recevez le
professeur jean françois delfraissy dans
pas très longtemps donc c'est lui qui
vous parlera au titre du conseil
scientifique
donc moi je parle en tant que voilà je
parle donc en tant que virologues d'un
laboratoire hospitalier et en même temps
responsable du centre national de
référence pour les virus respiratoires
donc ce que ce que vous dire c'est
typiquement de l'intérieur du cnr et de
l'hôpital on a vu progressivement se
mettre en place les outils accompagner
les outils et rencontrer l'ensemble des
difficultés qui au fil de l'eau
apparaissait avec très clairement une
notion de connaissances progressive qui
ont accumulé
il faut quand même bien voir que en
termes de de réponse alors on peut dire
effectivement que la stratégie testing
est aujourd'hui inadapté ou peut être en
difficulté mais il n'y a aucun pathogène
en france pour lequel on fait un million
de tests par semaine ça n'existe pas
c'est quelque chose pour lequel
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de comparateurs
qu'ils puissent être qui reste être
opposés en quelque sorte dans le sens où
il faut bien comprendre par exemple que
dans mon laboratoire qui est un gros
laboratoire de ca chute probablement un
des plus gros de france
aujourd'hui je fais par semaine plus de
tests coronavirus que je fais de tests
vih par an et donc ça pendant 52
semaines
donc c'est à dire qu'on fait cinquante
deux fois plus de tests coronavirus que
de tests vih
c'est juste c'est juste un élément de
comparaison la deuxième chose c'est que
le volume d'activité du laboratoire a
été augmentée de 50%
j'avais une production sa part a
peut-être à monsieur blanchecotte qui
était de 2 heures de 50 millions de
bébés hnr y achète on en est à plus de
75 jours à 80 ceci est lié au fait on a
été en capacité de d'essayer de répondre
sur à la fois des volumes d'activité
mais aussi de répondre à la demande
hospitalière les laboratoires
hospitaliers sont essentiellement
tournées vers la demande hospitalière et
cette demande était particulièrement
importante pendant la période de la du
confinement et elle reste très élevé
actuellement parce que dans le cadre
d'adp de l'évolution des techniques et
des outils un certain nombre de
plateformes diagnostic qui ont été
fournis par l'état sont adossés à des
laboratoires hospitaliers comme le mien
est donc on a eu la possibilité de
monter en puissance avec un
accompagnement qui est significative
puisque nous avons embauché 24 personnes
pour pouvoir faire tourner cette
plateforme 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur
24 qui est actuellement le mode de
fonctionnement du laboratoire aussi donc
est ce si ça a été ça a été le cas
pendant toute la période du confinement
jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin et on a
repris ce à partir du début du mois
d'août donc on a eu une semaine un mois
un petit peu plus calme et ce qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir un rendu qui
est alors certes plus simple plus rapide
que la moyenne et s'observer puisque le
rendu des résultats pour ma plateforme
en moyenne et à 18 heures
rey à l'hôpital hanover par rapport à
vos prélèvements mais on comprend tout
de suite la difficulté et ce sur quoi je
voudrais revenir aussi c'est un moment
donné vous expliquer la démarche qui est
le cnr pour la mise en oeuvre des outils
et l'accompagnement de ce que l'on a pu
faire pour les laboratoires hospitaliers
et les difficultés qu'on a pu rencontrer
au fil du temps parce que cette
situation était quand même terriblement
complexe on est aujourd'hui et je suis
d'accord avec françois blanchecotte dans
une espèce de croisée des chemins où
finalement on a une puissance analytique
qui est quand même considérable mais
qu'il faut qu'on leur il faut qu'on
organise mais il faut qu'on priorise le
les patients et les contacts et que
éventuellement nous on s'adapte pour le
dépistage qui est une autre philosophie
qu'à une volonté beaucoup plus santé
publique alors que le dépistage des
contacts et les patients c'est une
volonté médical stricto sensu
voilà je je je n'en dirai pas plus et je
répondrai aux différentes questions au
fil de l'eau en fonction de celles que
vous voudrez bien me poser je vous
remercie
merci professeur froguel même exercice
même temps d'abord je remercie de
l'honneur et de la confiance que me fait
en m'invitant à cette commission d
enquête
j'ai une particularité celle à la fois
professeur de médecine génomique à
londres où le dirigea un laboratoire et
un master de génétique humaine et
professeurs dans des thrillers ou au chu
de lille mais surtout je dirige un des
plus gros centre de génomique français
financé par le pays à la beck's equipex
et ih u2 ce qui veut dire que
l'extraction d'acides nucléiques apsr
c'est mon coeur de métier depuis 30 ans
et je le fais à très haut débit ce qui
m'autorise je crois donnait un avis
autorisé sur les tests que 8,19 que nous
avons pratiqué au printemps par ailleurs
je suis un des cinq médecins français
les plus cités au monde et donc je sais
écrire yuv et comprendre un article
scientifique ce qui m'a permis d'être un
lanceur d'alerté en particulier en
débusquant le premier en france
l'imposture du papier du lendemain sur
l'idh roxy chloroquine jeu plus en
souvenez probablement
je me suis intéressé au 10 rue si
coville 19 dès le mois de février en
lisant ce qui se passait en
en corée et j'ai découvert que nous
pouvions très bien faire nous mêmes
c'est à dire dans la recherche ces tests
pcr début mars j'ai alerter ma
hiérarchie hospitalo universitaires
proposer nos services
mais là ce que directeur général du chu
de lille qui s'appelle frédéric boiron
m'a répondu négativement avec faut bien
le dire un certain mépris car pour lui
nous n'étions que des chercheurs et nous
n'avions absolument pas faire de
diagnostic
heureusement je vais aussi aller voir le
dg de la rs haute france qui s'appelle
etienne champions et qui lui a très bien
compris la situation nouvelle
à la différence de mon directeurs de chu
il m'a dit exactement nous sommes entrés
dans l'ère des pénuries et le
réglementaire ne peut pas perdurer comme
avant et cheveux
je vous demande de bien réfléchir à
cette phrase et il a essayé en vain de
sensibiliser la direction générale de la
santé et donc j'ai dû organiser une
campagne médiatique et sur les réseaux
sociaux envoyé une note avec des
propositions de décret et d'arrêté au
premier ministre de l'époque edouard
philippe donc cabine a été très réceptif
qui ont amené à l'arrêté du 5 avril
autorisant les équipes de recherche et
de vétérinaires et de gendarmes a
contribué aux directives pcr hélas rien
n'a été simple après le 5 avril du fait
de l'hostilité de la plupart des
directions chu aussi des responsables de
pôles de de biologie médicale d'adp et
d'hôpitaux et des syndicats de
biologistes hospitalier qui redoutait
qu'on touche à leur monopole du
diagnostic en gros on ne voulait pas
qu'on fasse rentrer le loup dans la
bergerie
sur les 55 oratoire qui ont été recensés
par le gouvernement dans le cadre de cet
arrêté seule une poignée est arrivé à
signer des conventions de partenariat en
réalité de sous traitance que ceux ci a
été limitée dans l'arrêté pour pas
froisser nos collègues de logist
médicaux en réalité on a fait beaucoup
plus parce que on nous a demandé de
faire plus mon premier et mon labo été
le premier à le faire en france et ceci
avec un groupe privé qui s'appelle
synlab et cette collaboration a été
absolument exemplaire
c'est à ce moment là je crois mais il
madame les sénateurs qu'on a perdu la
bataille des tests pcr situant situation
que nous payons prix fort en ce moment
alors que la deuxième vague de la
pandémie arrive au galop
en effet à ce moment là le gouvernement
a rejeté la proposition de la communauté
la recherche génomique académiques
françaises et ceci malgré le soutien de
madame vidal et de son cabinet de faire
des grandes plates formes régionales de
diagnostic cette source est à très haut
débit
je veux dire au moins dix mille par jour
avec nos partenaires naturels achètent
encore s'il le voulait mais surtout
privé et je parle en particulier des
grands groupes de biologie comme si la
bio groupe ou servent allianz à qui les
gens commandent des très bonnes
relations
seuls ces plateformes serait capable
aujourd'hui de faire face en quelques
jours seulement à des megacoaster
localiser nécessitant de tester dans une
zone précise des dizaines de milliers de
personnes et ça a été fait comme ça en
chine en corée dans certains autres
endroits au contraire à mon avis le
gouvernement enchaîné les erreurs
il a d'abord vainement essayé
d'augmenter la production de test dans
les laboratoires de virologie
hospitalière en achetant ces fameux
robot chinois qui mal distribuée est
souvent mal utilisés
peut-être peut-être pas lyon mais dans
d'autres endroits que je connais bien
n'ont jamais changé la donne
ou du moins de manière marginale et ça
ça a été un échec
le gouvernement suit tout misé sur les
laboratoires privés acquis en ce moment
je crois sont 90% des tests pcr mais
sans les accabler parce qu'ils ne
méritent pas ils ont montré dans les
dernières semaines leurs limites
structurelles qui était d'ailleurs
prévisible en étant souvent incapables
de respecter leurs engagements de
rapidité de prélèvement et de rendu de
résultats en moins de 48 heures alors
que faire nos collègues médiatique
biologistes ou infectiologues vous même
ici à cette table demande partout qu'on
revienne à une interdiction de l'accès
direct aux tests de covile 19 de la
population française à mon avis et là je
vais vraiment diverger je crois ce que
ce droit est irréversible le
gouvernement n'y arrivera pas et parce
que
on revient pas sur ce genre de choses
comme m'a dit hier un dirigeant d'un de
ces grands groupes de laboratoires
privés au lieu d'essayer de restreindre
à nouveau l'accès des tests il faut
rester sur le dépistage de masse et
c'est au laboratoire privé à leurs
alliés de s'adapter en augmentant leur
capital leur capacité d' analyse en
diversifiant leurs fournisseurs et pas
en gérant la pénurie une nouvelle fois
et je partage pleinement cette opinion
et je pense une fois de plus que les
grands groupes des laboratoires privés
doivent travailler des experts de la
génomique à très haut niveau
trouvera pardon à très haut débit pour
monter enfin les plateformes nous avons
besoin pour terminer mon message est
très clair et très simple c'est l'accès
aux tests avec résultats en 24 heures
qu'ils soient naseaux salivaire pcr ou
même protéique et lui seul cet accès qui
peut permettre d'isoler attend les
porteurs de virus m'attend c'est sept
jours semble-t-il et d'arrêter les
contaminations enchaîne les masques que
nous réclamions tous depuis le printemps
sont désormais portés par tous et vous
avez remarqué ya aucun résultat magique
sur l'épidémie car en réalité ce ne sont
que des retardateurs de contamination et
je veux faire donner l'image qui s'est
un peu comme dans les feux de forêt les
liquides déversées par les canadair sont
aussi des retardateurs mais il faut
aussi les pompiers sur place pour
arrêter les feux si on ne règle pas
enfin la question des tests en france
plus de tests là où il en faut plus
rapide new fait et qu'on continue dans
l'erreur qui perdure depuis février on
va progressivement remplir n'aurait à
comme à marseille et en confinera encore
à nouveau comme nous annonce monsieur
delfraissy ce qui conduit rend encore
plus de robin encore plus de casse
sociale
errare humanum est perseverare
diabolicum j'aimerais que je vous
propose que votre commission en face sa
devise
merci merci c'est ce que nous attendons
de ces tables rondes une conf rate une
confrontation confraternel avec des
points de vue différents de façon à ce
qu'on puisse effectivement rendre
service à nos concitoyens et je suis sûr
que les questions de nos rapporteur ou
de nos commissaires vont vous passionner
je commence par qui aujourd'hui
catherine bernard et puis c'est lui
ça vous va aller catherine des roches
merci monsieur le président et merci à
vous trois de ses propos liminaires bon
il y aura une foultitude de questions à
poser sur les tests parce que on a
entendu hier la corée du sud et taiwan
qui nous ont expliqué comment avait été
leur stratégie depuis le départ alors
certes le contexte géographique spider
est différent mais il y avait quand même
cette proximité avec la chine mais ils
ont appliqué dès le départ la
stratégique était de tester tracé isolé
ce que nous n'avons pas fait en france
et je pense qu'on le paie alors on
souhaitait entendre l'allemagne
également sur ce sujet mais les
représentants allemands ont décliné
l'invitation parce qu'il ya quand même
cette comparaison qui se fait dès le
départ entre entre deux pays qui eux
sont dans la même situation pratiquement
moi on va parler de la situation
actuelle moi je voulais faire un peu un
retour en arrière
lorsqu'on avait entendu
un professeur fontanet lors de
l'audition sur la la crise du coc vide
dans l'oise et le cluster de l'oise il
avait évoqué le fait que l'institut
pasteur avait développé très tôt un
modèle de test c'est resident evil ce
sera comment l'expliquer mais qu'en fait
le retard après était venue de
l'incapacité française à produire ces
tests
qu'est ce qui explique cela c'est ma
première question
deuxièmement monsieur blanchecotte vous
avez évoqué des tensions internationales
si je peux dire sur du matériel d'où
vient le matériel que vous utilisez dans
vos laboratoires qu'il produit et
comment expliquer cette tension sur
l'accréditation des tests ou le
référencement
lorsqu'on avait dès début avril évoqué
auprès du ministre véran le problème des
laboratoires départementaux qui
pouvaient y avait des capacités de
tester l'autorisation a été très longue
et est ce que dans cette période qui
était une période d'urgence
ça c'est plus ce professeur lina qui
peut nous répondre comment se fait-il
qu'il ya eu un retard aussi long et
cette forme de d'administration très
très normative et très tatillonne dont
on peut entendre aussi les
l'utilité puisqu'il faut bien sécuriser
les procédures comment on n'a pas pu
accélérer accélérer toutes ses demandes
toutes ces demandes qui arrivait
troisième mission c'est sur les tests
salivaires ou a sonné et 4 et la
fiabilité des tests vous pouvez nous
dire parce que je rencontre à l'autre
d'un médecin du xviie médecins
généralistes qui me disaient j'ai eu de
cas de patients asymptomatiques était
positif et deux qui étaient
symptomatiques et qu'ils étaient
négatifs
est ce que ça tient aux prélèvements au
lieu du prélèvement de la piscine air
sur des formes peut-être comme on voit
qu'il ya des formes à la fois
neurologique si je puis dire pulmonaire
maintenant on annonce des formes m
génitales donc les complications
est ce que ça tient à ça donc quelle est
la fiabilité de ces tests nous explique
aussi par des cycles c'est très
compliqué mais si vous pouvez nous en
dire un mot
et comme on l'entend c'est dire que le
virus actuellement muterait du moins
dans sa forme mais traoré des
différences est ce qu'au fil du temps
vous avez est obligé de modifier le test
où on reste sur le même test au départ
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'articles qui
on entend tout et son contraire et c'est
pas fait pour rassurer la population
donc si vous pouvez répondre à ces à ces
trois questions et on arrête des tas
d'autres mais mes collègues j'ai posé
oui comment ce professeur nina je peux
essayer de commencer si jamais oubli des
éléments à appeler moi parce que il ya
effectivement beaucoup de questions
première chose il n'ya pas de mutation
dans le bios ya pas de mutation ce virus
il est stable il a au moment de son
déploiement à l'échelle planétaire
à un moment donné il y avait 3 et nos
groupes qui sont ils sont apparus il ya
un gène au groupe qui s'appelle jets
d'objets parce qu'il ya une substitution
qui survient une position 614 qui d'une
des protéines qui entraîne aucune
modification
simplement c'est un marqueur génétique
qui permet de suivre la diffusion des
virus comme ceux gérés au groupe g a été
introduit en europe et bien et que
l'europe a été l'épicentre de la
diffusion du virus à partir du mois de
février mars
et bien c'est pour cela que ce jeune
groupe a diffusé après dans les autres
pays qui ont été contaminés par
proximité via l'europe et notamment
d'amérique du nord puis après l'amérique
du sud et le reste du monde
donc là on a un système de surveillance
qui est basé sur le ms dans lequel je
suis beau sur lequel je suis branché
puisque je suis un expert de l'om est ce
aussi sur ce sujet-là qui permet de
vérifier tous les jours les séquences
génétiques qui sont déposées par les
différents laboratoires ya à peu près 90
milles séquences qui ont été réalisés ce
qu'il ya de nouveau ce qui est
considérable et on voit ces on voit ces
jeunes groupes
il n'y a aucune mutation qui
intrinsèquement entraîne une
modification de violence de
pathogénicité ou de transmissibilité ya
rien de documenter qui permettent de le
dire il ya une hypothèse qui est que sur
ce gène au groupe g qui est apparue en
février
donc on voit que c'était avant la
première vague ce jeu le groupe j aurais
in dans un tube à essai un tout petit
avantage réplicative par rapport aux
autres mais ça n'est pas observée chez
des individus
donc c'est juste pour vous répondre à
cette mutation il n'y a pas de mutation
c'est surveiller de façon extrêmement
étroites ses surveillants particulier
sur les zones d amorce qui sont qui sont
proposés par les différents centres sont
affrontés six contrôles il ya le chinois
le les américains qui ont proposé toute
une série d'amorcer puis de l'institut
pasteur aussi et il ya une amorce qui
aujourd'hui on observe quelques
modifications c'est une amorce qui en
fait n'est plus utilisé mais ça nous
permet d'avoir une certaine certitude
par rapport à la stabilité de la
possibilité de faire des tests
diagnostiques dans de bonnes conditions
avec ces dispositifs
donc ça permet de basculer vers la
fiabilité des tests en fait la fiabilité
des tests
il faut bien comprendre que quand on
analyse les tests il faut il faut
regarder deux choses il faut regarder et
vous l'a fort justement dit la qualité
du prélèvement et la qualité de
l'amplification qui est faite de la
détection en quelque sorte la qualité du
prélèvement je me suis beaucoup battu
pour qu'on maintienne le prélèvement
nasopharyngé parce que c'est le
prélèvement de référence ce virus se
réplique derrière dans la zone de
nasopharynx lots de l'europe un axe
c'est là c'est la clé essentielle de la
machinerie de production des vieilles se
trouve donc pour avoir les prélèvements
de plus sensibles les prêts demande naso
pharyngé qu'il faut faire ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on ne peut pas faire d'autres
prélèvements
mais que c'est en gros la référence et
que si on bascule sur d'autres types de
prélèvements il prendra dès salivaire
josiane où on en est il faut qu'on mette
ce ce type de prélèvement en parallèle
la deuxième chose les amplification et
les différents dispositifs qui existent
aujourd'hui il y en a plus d'une
vingtaine disponibles actuellement ils
sont ils ont été en grande partie évalué
parle par les laboratoires du cnr ils
sont fiables
ils sont ils sont robustes et permettent
de donner des réponses de qualité avec
des nuances en terme de performance mais
il y en a des actions à première depuis
son petit peu moins bon mais globalement
c'est un piège je reviens sur votre
exemple on a découvert dans le cadre de
l' on a découvert plus tôt on a
documenté dans le cadre du suivi de ces
épis de ces épidémies et des cas qui
effectivement il y avait des
asymptomatique et en particulier plutôt
chez les jeunes donc aujourd'hui chez
les jeunes pardon mais pas seulement oui
c est moi j'essaie de parler à la
personne qui m'a posé des questions je
donc donc c'est détection
asymptomatiques on l'est dont les
documents de plus en plus on l'a vu
assez assez tôt c'est au mois de mars
avril qui avaient des formes
asymptomatiques parce que ça venait
plutôt de l'étranger de chez nous parce
que nous on était focalisée sur les cas
en parallèle on a aussi parmi des
personnes qui présentent des signes
cliniques aujourd'hui des infections à
rhinovirus
aujourd'hui il ya plus de rhinovirus
coronavirus qui donne des infections des
voies rien supérieur dans le cadre du
centre national de référence sur la
surveillance communautaire
j'ai en proportion trois fois plus de
rhinovirus que de coronavirus chez les
patients donc à voir des signes
cliniques aussi peu symptomatiques aussi
pts peu pardon orientateur en quelque
sorte ouvert une pathologie cornaz virus
que ce qu'on a actuellement fait qu' il
ya un surdiagnostic et justement il ya
besoin de monter de temps en temps un
diagnostic différentiel de l'intérêt de
temps en temps de détection dit
multiplex qui permettent de détecter
plusieurs pathogènes dans l'échantillon
c'est ce que l'on fait nous pour
expliquer que monsieur ou madame machin
napal coronavirus en revanche il a bien
un autre où elle un bien un autre virus
qui est le rhinovirus actuellement et
donc il ya une circulation intense des
rhinovirus actuellement et donc ça peut
expliquer pourquoi se peut ça peut
expliquer je ne sais pas mais ça peut
être une des raisons pour lesquelles il
a des patients symptomatiques qui n'ont
pas de corps d'un virus mais ils ont
peut-être un autre virus ça peut être
aussi un diagnostic qui est manquée je
suis pas en train de dire que ce n'est
pas laid je n'ai pas l'information
puisque je n'ai pas des prélèvements
alors en fait je remontais le fils que
vous m'aviez des questions vous avez
posées concernant les autorisations pour
les utilisations pour l'utilisation des
autres laboratoires
on m'a demandé mon avis c'était une
décision qui a été prise au niveau
réglementaire la seule chose que je peux
vous dire c'est que ayant aussi à
l'abord de recherche en infectiologie
j'ai utilisé la ressource technique de
mon laboratoire de recherche pour
pallier à des difficultés qu'il y avait
à un moment donné pour faire des tests
diagnostiques
c'est compliqué parce que ça suppose une
logistique une organisation s'était lié
au fait parce qu'on n'était pas sur le
sur le même site que les tubes sont
enregistrés que on a une base
informatique sur lequel tout est
enregistré
dans le cadre de l'accréditation ce qui
était un petit peu évoquée par monsieur
blanchecotte c'est compliqué de déporter
des analyses ça c'est un aspect
réglementaire qui peut peut-être être
levé dans un contexte d'urgence c'est
une des choses que j'ai eu l'occasion de
proposer c'est à dire de considérer que
dans des contextes d'urgence un certain
nombre de règles peuvent tomber
spontanément pour faciliter alors là en
l'occurrence les tests diagnostics mais
ça peut être d'autres choses qui peuvent
être les qui peuvent être les essais
cliniques qui peuvent être plein de
choses il faut garder des il faut garder
des barrières mais malgré tout on peut
lever un certain nombre d'aspects
réglementaire qui freine et certains
laboratoires effectivement se sont
associés avec des laboratoires
vétérinaires quelques-uns avec deux
laboratoires de recherche
il y en a sur le mur n'a dans la région
lyonnaise aussi est objectivement le le
rendu de résultats à partir du moment où
c'est bien organisé bien structuré ne
pose pas de problème voilà et ça permet
effectivement d'augmenter la puissance
de tir mais on en croit ce que par
rapport aux tests et par rapport à son
utilisation on revient à une question
qui aujourd'hui extrêmement importante
dans le contexte temporel dans lequel on
appuie ce que vous savez que les
décisions qu'on prend aujourd'hui
n'auront un impact en termes de
dynamique épidémique que dans quinze
jours il est nécessaire effectivement et
c'est ce que nous avons un jeu prendre
pour le coup on dit que ma casquette de
conseil scientifique un tout petit peu
parce que ça fait partie de la vie qui
vient de sortir
nous recommandons donc une logique sur à
la fois les méthodes de dépistage les
méthodes diagnostiques les temps qui
correspondent à autant de cons de
d'isolement des patients et des cas
contact de façon à ce que il y ait une
vision claire de ce que l'on souhaite
faire une stratégie par rapport aux
tests de dépistage et aux tests
diagnostiques ce qui n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose et ça se fait ceci
dans un contexte d'évolution technique
je finirai par ça puisque on a abordé
très rapidement les tests salivaires les
tests antigénique alors il faut bien
comprendre que quand on parle de tests
salivaires
faux pas il ya 2 il ya deux éléments
dedans il y as que la salive est un bon
prélèvements pour faire un diagnostic
parce qu'après on peut faire de la pcr
on peut faire la détection antigénique
on peut faire d'autres techniques de
détection ça c'est la première question
il ya une étude en cours actuellement
conjointement entre mon laboratoire le
laboratoire de camp et des préleveurs
qui sont en guyane puisque la guyane
avait beaucoup beaucoup de cas quand on
a commencé ce travail c'est en cours
d'évaluation des résultats vont
probablement sortir dans une semaine ou
deux et on va pouvoir avoir une vision
claire de ce que comment on peut
transposer de prélèvement salivaire au
parlement nasopharyngé quels sont les
atouts quelles sont les limites
il faut voir que on part dans un système
de dépistage et la plupart des
publications qui ont été faites ont été
faites chez des patients hospitalisés
avec un prélèvement salivaire le matin
au réveil c'est pas la vie vrai ça c'est
pas l'habit vrai le papier du new
england ne vous raconte pas la vivrai il
vous raconte pas ce qui se passera dans
un système de dépistage massif puisque
c'est pas des patients que vous prélevez
le matin au réveil
or on sait que comme pour la tuberculose
par exemple on quand on prélevait les
crachats le matin ils étaient beaucoup
plus informatif que quand on veut
prélever le soir parce qu'il ya une
collecte des pathogènes dans dans les
voies aériennes supérieures pendant
pendant la nuit tout simplement donc
c'est très logique
c'est très logique donc il n'empêche
qu'on voit que ces opportunités de
basculer sur des systèmes de
prélèvements simple à haut débit est
quelque chose qui est un enjeu majeur et
on a on commence à faire les évaluations
des tests antigénique il ya des travaux
qui sont faits sur la psp des travaux
qui sont faits dans mon laboratoire
aussi à des travaux qui sont faits dans
d'autres laboratoires
on a tendance à pas croire les
fournisseurs qui nous vendent du rêve
parce que le fournisseur quand vous
l'écoutez c'est 100% de sensibilité il y
a il est nécessaire et de nouveau parce
que si on le faisait pas vous me feriez
revenir dans trois mois en me disant
mais comment ça se fait que vous ayez
pas fait l'évaluation tout ça avant
qu'on les utilise donc on fait ces
évaluations on commence à voir des
résultats on commence à savoir où se
positionne la sensibilité
et ces tests antigénique par rapport à
la référence qu'il rt pcr sur
prélèvement nasopharyngé est de nouveau
ça va nous permettre de décliner sa pour
savoir comment est-ce qu'on peut les
utiliser en vie vrai et ça va permettre
potentiellement de réduire les dates en
notamment dans le cadre du dépistage qui
est la demande la plus importante
aujourd'hui vous faites bien la nuance
entre dépistage et diagnostic c'est pas
de la biologie moléculaire
non les tests antigénique c'est une
détection en face et comment dire il ya
ce qu'on appelle le latéral flou qui est
en fait simplement une bandelette vous
déposez un peu d'échantillons sur dans
une qq l'on surnomme sa les savonnettes
dans nos laboratoires et et après il ya
ça migrent sur sur un papier et si la
protéine du virus que l'on cherche et
présente il ya une bande qui s'éclaire
et qui permet de voilà comment on fait
pour pour la pour langil à streptocoque
exactement voilà j'espère avoir répondu
non nous avait parlé s'agit fontanel
lorsqu'on entend que oui effectivement
dans le retard alors en fait dans lequel
ans les événements
le virus est séquencée le 7 janvier ce
qui permet et qui est partagée
immédiatement la communauté
internationale ce qui permet de faire
justement le travail pour fabriquer des
cibles d amorcer des chambres très
rapidement la charité qui est le
l'hôpital le
le laboratoire qui se trouve à berlin
piloté par christian dreux stand propose
un jeu d'un jeu d'abord cette séquence
que le cnr acquiert très rapidement en
parallèle l'institut pasteur développe
un jeu d'amos ils ont des jobs il on
développe plusieurs que au fil du temps
on optimise le premier patient française
c'est le 23 janvier le dernier qui
portait le 24 et on utilise et après on
a on a le petit groupe des sept patients
paris des cinq patients parisien et du
patient et du patient bordelais qui sont
les premiers 4 l'on a on utilise les
prêts d'émancipation pour vérifier que
nos dispositifs sont performants et ça
nous permet aussi d'avoir un virus qui
permet aussi de tester ans vivrait les
capacités de diagnostic on se rend
compte rapidement que le test qui a été
développé par un pistolet ce du pasteur
présente une supériorité analytique
c'est à dire qu'il est un petit peu plus
sensible que le test développé par la
charité
puisque tu une bonne nouvelle a priori
mais vous verrez que finalement ça se
retourne contre nous parce que
maintenant on dit qu'on met trop
sensible et le à ce moment là il n'y a
pas de cas en france le 7 le 7 février à
paray le cluster de contamines le
cluster de contaminer mon laboratoire
qu'il a gérée on a fait quoi on a fait
un diagnostic rapide grâce à ses outils
de la charité de l'institut pasteur des
patients les prélèvements ont été faits
à 14h à contamine le résultat est sorti
à 21h à lyon parce qu'en fait pour vous
dire pour l'anecdote les les
échantillons ont voyagé en hélicoptère
donc pour être pour ne pas perdre de
temps et ça nous a permis de mettre ses
patients en isolement dans les
laboratoires dans les services
hospitaliers y en avait à saint-etienne
à grenoble et à lyon et ça nous a permis
en même temps de continuer à apprendre
un tout petit peu ça et ce dont on s'est
rendu compte à ce moment là ça ne vous
en parle c'est que la sonde fournis par
la charité était contaminée on avait des
résultats faussement positifs et ça
c'est pas c'est pas à cause de la
charité c'est le fournisseur qui avait
synthétiser la sonde avait mis dans la
sonde aussi haut
chose d amorce qui entraînait des
résultats faussement positifs et tous
les laboratoires français à qui on avait
fourni ce matériel se retrouvait avec
des résultats potentiellement contaminés
donc il a fallu tout jeter à la poubelle
mais c'est pas ce n'était pas un
problème franco français
c'était un problème sur un fournisseur
international donc ce qui fait que à la
home mi février
la plupart des laboratoires qui était en
charge du diagnostic ont dû faire tomber
une partie de leurs outils et redemander
de la synthèse et alors là c'était le
chaos
c'était le chaos parce que il n'y avait
pas de synthèse possible en volume
suffisant par rapport à la demande qui
était fait pour pouvoir alimenter tous
les laboratoires européens qui faisaient
la demande de matériel alors il y avait
plusieurs fournisseurs donc on a essayé
de jouer avec les fournisseurs on a eu
de la chance parce que nous on est
prudent on avait demandé des synthèses
fait par deux fournisseurs différents il
y en avait qu'un seul qui posait
problème donc on a utilisé l'autre
sachez par exemple que ce matériel là
c'est ce que j'ai envoyée à philippe
brouqui à marseille quand il a fallu
qu'ils fassent le dépistage des patients
qui rentrait de l'avion devone donc on
lui a envoyé du matériel pour qu'ils
puissent faire ce test parce qu'il
n'avait pas la ressource de nouveau il
était dans le même problème
il n'avait plus de cendres donc il ne
pouvait plus faire cette paix serre et
après on s'est trouvé dans une autre
difficulté c'est quelque chose qui est
abordé à un moment donné puis après j'ai
arrêté parler parce que je suis très mal
à le le le
quand on a commencé à vouloir déployer
un petit peu ça c'est une question qui a
été posée on s'est retrouvé dans une
certaine difficulté parce que des
laboratoires hospitaliers non plus que
des machines qui travaillent sur des
systèmes fermés
en fait les fournisseurs aujourd'hui
vous donne un dispositif clé en main
alors je fais une analogie qu'un petit
peu idiote mais si vous avez un solex et
que vous arrivez pas avoir de solexine
vous pouvez pas faire marcher votre
solex et bien quand on a des outils qui
sont sur des outils fermé parce que dans
le cadre de l'accréditation on est
obligé de travailler comme ça on est
obligées on ne peux pas accréditer il ya
que les cnr qui peuvent le faire des
techniques manuelles et c'est ça ou et
c'est là où un certain nombre de
laboratoires se sont retrouvés en
difficulté parce que même si on leur
donnait les outils pour faire les pcr il
n'avait plus la ressource technique
simple et qui effectivement présentes
dans des laboratoires de recherche pour
faire de la pcr dit manuel et donc et
après bon on travail d'évaluation on a
évalué cinq procédures d'extraction
différentes
on a testé des deux machines on s'est
rendu compte que certaines machines ne
marchait pas et qu'on avait des
résultats faussement négatifs parce que
l'extraction ne marchait pas en
comparaison d'autres qui marchait très
bien
on a fait optimisée des choses bref je
pourrais vous raconter un tout petit peu
ce qu'on a fait mais en fait pendant ça
explique une partie des retards en tout
cas ça explique une partie du retard à
l'allumage
ouais professeur voguette attendons
simplement je voulais m'excuser auprès
du professeur fontanes et que j'appelais
xavier ce n'est pas le même il s'appelle
arnaud vous nous avions tous compris
professeur philippe alors d'abord sur la
variabilité du virus
moi je parle pas de la de la sexualité
et la virulence ce qui est vraiment pas
ma méconnaissance simplement sur le plan
de la pcr à partir du moment où on
utilise plusieurs paires de prime heures
et que les mutations n'ont pas porté sur
landreau se fixer les primeurs
ça ne peut pas avoir d'incidence sur le
test pcr qui est le sujet d'aujourd'hui
donc simplement pour pour rassurer tout
le monde
herman s'il y avait d'autres mutations
et ça serait possible mais je penserai
ce moment là on changera les primeurs
mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut c'est
quand c'est les virus pour savoir si par
malheur il n'ya pas des mutations qui
vont faire que les préleveurs ne se
fixeront pas au bon endroit
ça c'était le premier point le deuxième
point ce qui ressort tout à fait et ça
correspond à ce que j'avais entendu ces
contrôles mois de février mars et après
et après il ya eu un travail qui a été
fait par le cnr pasteurien un peu sol
qui est parfois contradictoires risque à
des ferrailleurs par exemple sur les et
rod les fameux tron qui ont été
autorisés ensuite après évaluation par
le cnr moi j'ai fourni à l'elysée des
résultats d'analysés qui a été fait par
servent alliance et par synlab qui
montrait 80% de cette robe était de
qualité très très très médiocre et
pourtant ma grande surprise ils ont été
ensuite homologuer par le cnr ce qui m'a
un peu surpris sur la d'abord il a fallu
beaucoup de temps senneurs pasteurien
pour faire et ensuite pour arriver à
faire c'est accepter à peu près tout ça
m'a un petit peu un petit peu surpris
selon des tests sérologiques ont parlé
sérologique et pas d'été spécial et rod
sont les tests sérologiques en ce qui
concerne le reste les maires les
extracteurs dahir n allez les
différentes protocole faut pas non plus
considérez que c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement compliqué à faire parce
que j'ai remarqué que c'était assez
compliqué dans les service de virologie
où il n'y avait pas de recherche et
développement et qu' il fonctionner un
système avec le cofrac avec le mode de
fonctionnement où tout était compliqué
et tout était lent nous quand on en a eu
l'autorisation en vers le 15 avril de
fonctionner nous a fallu une semaine
pour acheter pour accueillir un robot
vérifier qu'ils extraient qu'aurélie
perkin elmer qui extrayait correctement
la même qualité que ce que faisait notre
partenaire de syllabes en utilisant
roche et ensuite de faire de comparer
des échantillons quant à envoyer des
coups ont été testés des deux côtés pour
voir qu'on avait à peu près les mêmes
les mêmes résultats
on a monté aussi à une chaîne
informatique un links c'est-à-dire de
suivi tout ça a été fait parce que parce
que dans les laboratoire de génomique
on a des informaticiens ce qui existe
quasiment plus dans les hôpitaux on a
des bus informaticiens on a des
ingénieurs de recherche et tout ce
qu'elle semblait vachement compliqué à
pas mal de mes collègues à y compris
biologiste privé a été extrêmement
facile pour nous parce que c'est notre
métier et notre métier c'est de
justement de tester ça alors dire qu'un
extracteur ne marche pas là encore c'est
ça me fait un peu rire c'est que c'est
comme les fameux robot chinois qui n'ont
pas marché pendant des mois dans
certains chu comme marché très vite dans
d'autres le pas marché c'est simplement
possible dans un grand nombre de cas
c'est quand c'est pas les faire marcher
parce que ces basses et c'est compliqué
c'est comme faire une recette d'un grand
chef trois étoiles vous n'avez pas
toujours chez vous du premier coup ou
jamais vannes où les chercheurs de
génomique lors on y arrive parce que
c'est notre métier c'est pour ça que je
pense que on s'est vraiment vraiment
privé le cnr les laboratoires de
biologie médicale hospitalière se sont
vraiment privés d'une expertise très
forte car il ya des centre de génomique
qui sont pas simplement vous votre unité
inserm
monsieur mais qui a aussi des vrais
centre de génomique qui eux étaient
capables de développer ça rapidement
puisqu'en quand on nous l'a demandé on a
été capable de le faire
aux etats unis le broad institute qui
est le plus gros laboratoire de
génomique kullmann du monde a fait un
million de tests et donc tout ça c'est
véritablement véritablement possible d'y
et d'y arriver et je pense qu'on a perdu
beaucoup beaucoup de temps d'abord en
respectant des procédures anti
diluviennes qui se comprennent comme un
homme comme dim
rosheim a dans la en cas de paix mais en
cas de guerre et on les a trop respectés
beaucoup trop haut trop longtemps et ça
n'a bloqué beaucoup de choses on aurait
pu augmenter le nombre de tests très
rapidement comme l'ont fait les
allemands parce que vous citiez les
allemands s'il n'y avait pas eu une
sorte de malthusianisme et de blocage et
ça entraînait qu en fait personne a été
très peu de gens étaient testés hors des
hôpitaux jusqu'à en gros jusqu'à la fin
avril début mai merci professeur blanc
le docteur blanchecotte vous souhaitez
quelques précisions premièrement je sais
pas si vous n'avez rien à dire n'hésitez
pas on a toujours des choses à dire mais
on va pas compliquer la situation
qu'elle soit polémique en tout cas j'ai
jamais prononcé le mot d'interdiction de
test de mass enfin jusqu'à mon preuve du
contraire on vérifiera sur
l'enregistrement mais globalement
j'ai jamais dit cela en ce qui concerne
les plateformes aujourd'hui la plupart
des plateformes effectivement dont le
professeur choisel citer les noms sont
des plateformes effectivement qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à dix mille voire 25
mille tests par jour sur paris c'est ce
que nous avons vous savez si on était un
groupe est effectivement j appartiens
donc c'est c'est cela la question qui a
été posée par la sénatrice c'était
surtout pour les achats et en fait comme
vous l'avez vu et nous nous sommes
contraints dans le privé non pas nous ne
sommes pas dit d'abord auteur de chasse
nous ne pouvons pas qualifiés des
machines donc nous achetons clés en main
pour vous dire aujourd'hui que nous
achetons cash
contrairement à peut-être l'état où je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas nous on est
obligé de payer des machines avant
qu'elle arrive c'est comme ça que se
passe le marché mondial donc il faut
quand même avoir un petit peu de
trésorerie pour le faire et donc c'est
pas des machines qu'ils ne valent qu'un
franc ou un euro donc c'est très
compliqué en ce qui concerne les panels
de machines aujourd'hui faut savoir que
les fournisseurs on vous l'avait dit se
sont mis et volumes aujourd'hui les
fournisseurs avec lesquels nous
travaillons habituellement des grands
fournisseurs européens qui sont ces des
fournisseurs qui au départ n'était pas
prêt donc on était plutôt sûr marché
chinois le marché coréen et comme vous
l'avez répéter un des nos interlocuteurs
les tests que nous avons validé qualifié
au départ n'était pas de bonne qualité
donc ça veut dire que en plus vous
commandez mais vous planter donc c'est
très important de le savoir
ensuite aujourd'hui les machines qui
sont des machines dans le qui peuvent
permettre d'un côté faire l'extraction
de l'autre côté d'amplification t'es pas
des machines qu'on avait au départ il y
avait beaucoup de machines qu'on a
acheté qui était plutôt sûr du
transposition manuel de tubes à mettre
dans un dans une pipette etc
adam et voilà et donc cette
automatisation là elle est venue au fur
et à mesure aujourd'hui on a plutôt
affaire à des machines
hormis roche qui fait du tout-en-un
plutôt des machines en séquences 2
c'est-à-dire une première partie des
stations une deuxième amplification mais
globalement nous nous sommes soumis à
des règles et ces règles ne peuvent être
que simplement le panel de machines que
l'état valide
d'une manière générale puisque non
remboursement et la france prend en
charge ce ce paiement c'est pas gratuit
bien sûr et donc ça prend en charge ce
paiement dont
ces carcans là en fait qu'ils étaient
difficiles et la plateforme duster qui a
été mise en place par le gouvernement
pour nous en tout cas ne correspond pas
à nos besoins dans l'efficience de la
commande et la rapidité de la commande
donc nous sommes obligés aujourd'hui
dans les grandes plateformes que nous
avons deux d'avoir plusieurs
fournisseurs différents 3-4-5 des fois
et le seul le seul bémol qu'on fait
aujourd'hui par rapport à la réponse que
nous pourrions faire sur des dépistage
de masse c'est qu'aujourd'hui le délai
de entre le moment de la commande et
moment de la livraison est plutôt à se
multiplient par deux ou par trois c'est
ça c'est ça notre problématique
aujourd'hui c'est pas qu'on anticipe pas
c'est qu'à un moment donné même si vous
commandez le 15 août on aura des choses
le 15 septembre
donc évidemment aujourd'hui dans la
situation au jour où je vous parle il ya
un certain nombre de structures qui ont
des commandes en cours qui ont des
grandes effectivement machine en haut
débit qui sont en commande
mais qui n'ont pas reçu aujourd'hui de
livraison et comme comme nous l'a dit
après c'est une semaine de qualification
bon après on les met en oeuvre et on
respecte les procédures et tout pour
revenir un chose que les tests
salivaires ça sera exactement la même
machine pour nous sauf que on attend des
autorités scientifiques gît à côté de
moi qu'elle nous dise si sur nos
machines actuelles nous pouvons utiliser
un prélèvement salivaire
c'est différent aucune certitude pour
l'instant on a ici un an après d'accord
donc dernières chaussures lange continue
que bruno le professeur bruno lina a dit
c'est cette notion de diagnostic
différentiel
je vous rappelle qu'en france aucun test
multiplex nettes autorisé pour le privé
ni remboursé ni à notre nomenclature ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui si vous me
demandez de faire une pcr grippe ou une
paix sert coronavirus aujourd'hui
techniquement je peux le faire je n'ai
pas la possibilité ni deux le côté ni
d'avoir une prescription médicale qui
m'autorise à le faire d'accord il faut
que cela soit clair pour tout le monde
parce qu'entre le l'hôpital qui fait un
certain nombre d'examens y compris du
vih elle nous nous sommes dans un
système de remboursement de prise en
charge des français et donc on a une
nomenclature je le redis aujourd'hui
elle est obsolète l2
et ça accélérait j'espérais qu'en temps
de crise on aurait un accélération
formidable de notre métier aujourd'hui
une des raisons principales pour quoi
nous étions pas par rapport à nos
collègues allemands qui ont des
plateformes roche autre chose et
beaucoup de tests de biologie
moléculaire
nous n'avons aujourd'hui dans le privé
peut test de biologie moléculaire alors
qu'ils peuvent toucher tous les domaines
je suis pas le suis pas scientifique
mais globalement c'est c'est quand même
une évolution majeure de notre
nomenclature aujourd'hui on n'est pas le
riz cloud a rapidement professeur lina
une précision oui de deux petites
précisions sur les prélèvement salivaire
et les tests salivaires c'est pas de la
même chose près du vent c'est l'hiver
effectivement on les utilisera en rt pcr
sur les plates formes qui existera donc
en fait on ne fait que changer le
prélèvement après il ya dans la tête de
beaucoup de gens quand on parle des
tests salivaires il y à des tests des
kits clé en main ou cd dispositif
complet où vous avez le prélèvement qui
va dans une machine et c'est la machine
qui vous donne le résultat est là c'est
des systèmes d'amplification qui sont
différents qui s'appelle de la lampe
c'est en fait de l'amplification
isotherme qui permet d'avoir dans
certaines conditions des réponses
relativement rapide avec une petite
perte de sensibilité par rapport à la
pcr de nouveaux seins c'est le
comparateur qu'on essaye de faire et ces
dispositifs qui sont en cours
d'évaluation pour voir si on peut les
utiliser en routine
cette fois être intéressant parce que
ces deux c'est du matériel qu'on peut de
déporter sur site
si vous aussi vous avez une intervention
à faire dans une ehpad vous pouvez
emmener votre machine avec vous vous la
branchez façon machine à café pour le
coup et vous pouvez avoir un certain
nombre de réponses rapides directement
sur site
voilà en c'est en cours d'évaluation
c'est moi ça c'est toujours pareil à il
ya le temps médiatique le temps
politique le 30 biologique et le temps
de la recherche
quand même enfin en période de guerre un
peu on travaille dessus
je ne suis pas tout seul à travailler
dessus c'est un consortium qui était
encore une réunion téléphonique hier
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui ait
fait conjointement l'ap-hp enfin fait un
très gros travail dessus actuellement
très rapidement ne veut pas vous dire le
nombre de jours mais c'est ça se compte
en
ce sera avant la fin du mois de toute
façon il s'est probablement un petit peu
avant alors il faut le commander il
existe le matériel de place à ben oui il
existe en partie c'est juste on est dans
une phase d'évaluation que ça peut aller
très vite ça peut aller vite l'envié à
d'autres dispositifs de phase i/ii
autres d'autres machines qui peuvent
faire ça je voudrais juste dire une
chose aussi c'est qu'aujourd'hui on voit
des effets de bord par rapport à la
halle et fait qu vide c'est
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
laboratoires ne reçoivent plus les
réactifs pour d'autres pathogènes et en
particulier vous savez qu'on a deux
autres pathogènes qu'on surveille en
particulier pour les immunodéprimés qui
sont l'extrême bar et le cytomégalovirus
on a eu des messages des producteurs qui
nous disent que du fait qu'ils
augmentent la production pour les
réactifs tsar skov il y aura une pénurie
sur la fourniture d'autres réactif pour
d'autres pathogènes évidemment excusez
moi mais en ce qui concerne les lampes
et ce dont parlait là j'aimerais qu'un
corps concerné marié qu'on est en la
france c'est pas le monde entier et
qu'il ya des gens qui sont en avance sur
nous imperial college qui est mon
université britannique a mis au point un
test lamp et le gouvernement brittany
lang c'est à dire qu'ils ont bien parlé
c'est à dire une amplification isotherme
à partir de salive et le gouvernement
britannique a commandé imperial college
il ya un mois cinq millions de tests
pour 160 millions de livres sterling
j'étais extrêmement étonné que le
conseil scientifique et personne ne
parle de ce genre de choses si en france
on est plus lent que les autres pour
plein plein de raisons y compris pour
les tests thérapeutique
pour maryse essais thérapeutiques qu'on
a fait pour discovery en angleterre il
ya des pays et en allemagne mais sentant
en angleterre on est capable d'aller
plus vite et donc c'était s'il existe
sur le marché mondial gouvernement
britannique
les a commandées je ne sais pas quand
ils seront livrés et mais quand même une
fois de plus des gens comme moi qui
regarde ce qui se passe à l'étranger qui
travaillent dans plusieurs pays je
m'aperçois que on est un peu à la traîne
en france
je trouve que les comités qui se
réunissent par téléphone qui machin les
sous et cetera c'est très bien mais il
ya des gens qui vont plus vite
il faudrait peut-être s'intéresser à ce
que font ces gens qui vont plus vite
excusé moi les poils à gratter mais si
je il faut bien qu'il y en ait un
voilà pour cette table ronde consacrée à
la politique de dépistage table ronde
organisée dans le cadre de la commission
d' enquête sur la gestion de l'épidémie
de coronavirus le dépistage un sujet
toujours aussi brûlant et dont on risque
de parler encore dans les prochains mois
sur public sénat rester avec nous
[Musique]
je